Move over a little bit.
I seem right.
Three,
two,
one.
Yes.
Alright,
welcome back Chris.
What's up man?
How's.
Thanks.
Happy to be here.
Things are good.
How many have you?
Yeah.
What's the latest and the greatest view?
A new book came out yesterday.
That's always a big one.
What's called a unconventional medicine.
And uh,
give us the,
what is it,
what are those sheets?
The back sheet called to the.
Yeah,
the backseat not works.
Um,
the biggest challenge we face today is
chronic disease and conventional
medicine has failed to address it.
So we need a new system.
That's the nutshell.
And you're essentially,
I'm doing nutrition based,
uh,
for the three components,
ancestral diet and lifestyle,
which we've talked about,
a functional medicine and a
collaborative practice model that
incorporates health coaches,
nutritionists,
and other allied providers to,
to offer more support to patients.
What does that mean when you say
functional medicine?
So the easiest way to understand it,
it is,
it's an approach that is geared towards
addressing the underlying cause of a
problem instead of just suppressing the
symptoms.
So you go into the doctor,
you've got a high cholesterol,
usually given a drug to lower it
statens.
Yup.
You got high blood pressure and those
are devastating your health,
right?
Statens or.
Well,
you know,
for some people they can be.
I wouldn't say they're devastating for
everybody and they do save lives in
certain situations.
But the idea that they're the first
thing we,
we would do in that situation.
That's what's off that.
You wouldn't suggest like altering the
diet.
Exactly.
Let's look at why the cholesterol is
high in the first place.
Same thing with high blood pressure.
You go into the doctor,
high blood pressure,
you get a drug to lower it,
there's rarely any investigation and
your blood pressure is high.
And what are the main factors that high
cholesterol?
Because I know that um,
it's a big part of it is hereditary.
Yeah,
right.
Genetics play a huge role.
Yeah.
So the genetics is one for sure.
Uh,
but then you have things like poor
thyroid function can actually lead to
high cholesterol or Ldl particle number.
You've got infections can do that.
Like h Pylori,
which is the bacteria that causes ulcer
a,
you've got leaky gut.
Intestinal permeability has been shown
to do that.
That's interesting that you did you talk
about this before,
but a lot of people are not aware of
that,
that there's actually gut bacteria that
causes ulcers.
Yeah.
There's a.
it's a.
it's a cool story actually,
so you know,
20,
30 years ago that the dominant idea was
ulcers were caused by stress and things
like eating spicy foods and a couple of
Australian physicians presented at a
conference.
This notion that,
no,
actually they're caused by this bacteria
called helicobacter pylori,
and they were literally laughed off the
stage.
Nobody took them seriously.
They were ridiculed and they kept going.
I kept doing this research,
kept trying to present this idea and
nobody take them seriously.
Finally,
one of them swallowed a vial of,
have a solution that had the bacterium
in,
in it,
developed an ulcer as a result,
and then treated himself with
antibiotics and got rid of the ulcer to
approve this is how committed this guy
was,
this idea and proving this.
And finally at that point people started
to pay attention,
but it's still was another 10 years
before that theory was widely accepted
and then they eventually won the Nobel
prize in medicine as a result of that
discovery.
So that,
to me,
that's a great example of how group
think is such a problem in medicine.
You know,
we have a tendency to just like get
stuck on the status quo,
even though a core principle of sciences
uncertainty,
you know,
like we don't,
we,
we come up with a hypothesis.
We have to be willing to challenge our
most cherished views all the time.
Um,
because if we look at the history of
science,
it was the history of most people being
wrong about most things most of the
time.
Yeah.
And it's amazing how many people are
still operating under information that
has been updated many times over the
past couple of decades.
But absolutely talk to the average
person about what you should eat.
I mean they're looking at like the food
pyramid from the Dr Seuss books.
Really?
Yeah.
Or another one is you probably saw some
articles like stents have.
They don't work.
Yeah.
I just read that just came out with they
don't work,
but there's still a massively being used
in part because they get a doctors get
paid for that now.
That's crazy because I thought a stent
was like,
I thought it propped open the artery.
I mean what does it do?
Right.
And,
but the question is,
does that actually have the desired
effect?
I mean the thing was based on pain
resident,
wasn't it?
And mammograms prevent,
we're supposed to prevent breast cancer.
They don't.
Then we saw the huge randomized
controlled trial that showed that not
only did they not prevent breast cancer,
they may actually increase death either
as a result of unnecessary treatments
that come from the mammogram.
So yeah.
How,
how would you get an unnecessary trip?
Like if you did a mammogram and you saw
a lump,
well it's not always black or white,
so it could be a cyst or something
unless somebody gets unnecessary
treatment and that lends that leads to
an adverse event.
So I'm just saying it's,
you know,
we got to be humble and realize that we
don't always have the answers and that
in 10 years it's going to look really
different than it does now.
Just like a hundred years ago,
everybody thought they had the answers
and you know,
we look back on them and we say how
silly,
you know,
but we forget that people are 100 years
ahead are going to look back on us with
that same.
You know,
that they're going to shake their heads.
Yeah.
It's very unfortunate.
But that is a tendency that people have
when they've been living their life
based on what they think is like certain
rigid information.
Like this is absolute,
this is true.
And they've been teaching that.
That's when it gets especially
problematic or writing books about that.
Yeah.
And then they just never want to admit
that their book is bullshit and I think
the,
our education system needs to change
medical education because you know,
you write a textbook and that takes a
long time and then,
you know,
the textbook is used in,
in,
in chorus,
like the medical schools are still using
the nutrition textbooks that were
probably written in the seventies,
the eighties or something.
And then we get all these new studies
showing that like cholesterol in the
Diet makes,
has no impact on your blood cholesterol
for most people.
Say that again,
because for a lot of people who live
like,
what did he just say?
Yeah.
So,
uh,
even the American standard us diet
guidelines last year,
a lot of people might've missed this.
They completely removed any restriction
on dietary cholesterol from the,
from the US diet guidelines.
They basically said there's no reason to
limit cholesterol in your diet anymore.
Now for people who don't know why this
is so crazy or how this came to be,
you need to go to the New York Times
article on how the sugar industry bribe
scientists and convinced scientists to
publish faulty or false information
pointing toward saturated fats and
cholesterol as being the cause of heart
disease and heart attacks and all these
different elements so that they could
push the blame away from sugar and I
think they only got paid something like
$50,000
to do it.
Yeah.
Well,
she's amazing when you think about how
many people that's affected.
Yeah.
And these,
I mean,
these conflicts of interest are
everywhere.
It's a big topic of interest.
I mean,
that's just,
that's just crime,
right?
But it's horrible things to people.
It totally,
you know,
it's unfortunately pretty normal in
medicine.
There was a study that just came out a
few days ago that showed that the more
gifts doctors receive from
pharmaceutical companies,
the more expensive the drugs they
prescribe and the more prescriptions
they write in general.
Yeah,
I would imagine that's true.
Um,
my wife's mom was a nurse and she would
tell me stories about how they would
take them out to nice dinners at fancy
restaurants and everything on the house.
And it's human nature.
I mean,
you know,
up to one of my favorite quotes is from
Upton Sinclair.
He said it's difficult to get a man to
understand something when his salary is
dependent on him not understanding it.
That's a great quote.
Yeah.
So one more time,
dietary cholesterol has no impact.
Yeah.
Well,
I'll be more specific.
So in 70 percent of people eating egg
yolks and cholesterol and meat and other
things doesn't do anything to your serum
cholesterol.
The cholesterol levels in your blood,
in 30 percent of people,
you'll get a slight raise in your ldl
cholesterol,
the so called bad cholesterol,
but you also get a raise in your hdl
cholesterol,
which is a so called good cholesterol,
which means there's no net clinical
impact of that in terms of your risk of
heart disease.
And this is why the US finally the last
industrialized country to actually do
this.
They finally said,
okay,
well we really just can't do this
anymore.
We can't tell you not to eat dietary
cholesterol because there's just not any
evidence to support that.
What took so long?
Well,
I think you just referred to one of the
reasons,
you know,
conflicts of interest,
people that were invested in maintaining
the status quo.
I think also there's probably some
concern about losing credibility,
you know,
these organs,
these government organizations,
if they told you,
told us not to eat cholesterol for so
long and then they tell us that we can
and it's not a problem and they do that
with saturated fat.
You know,
people stop listening because they just
throw up their hands.
They're like,
I don't know who to believe or what to
listen to.
That saturated fat is another one.
You talked to the average person.
They think you should restrict your
intake of saturated fat.
Yeah,
average person.
Most doctors still.
And,
um,
you know,
I,
I think,
I think there is some nuance here and,
and you know,
maybe we talked about this on the last
show,
but where we're headed in my opinion
with diet and nutrition recommendations
is from general blanket recommendations
that apply to everybody to more
personalized recommendations that depend
on your genetics,
your goals,
your lifestyle,
you know,
uh,
your health status,
your age,
etc.
So let's take somebody who is apo e
four,
which is a,
you know,
have a certain genetic haplotype and
they have a,
you know,
they're,
they are really sensitive to the dietary
effects of saturated fat if you have
that gene type and if they eat the
common,
is that not very common at all?
Um,
I,
I can't remember the exact percent.
It'S below 10 percent.
I think it's three point three,
four percent or something like that.
And if those people eat a lot of
saturated fat,
their ldl particle number,
which we can define if you want to,
those are the particles that carry
cholesterol can go up pretty pretty
quickly.
And what we know,
at least from the research that we have
is that people who have a much higher
ldl particle number can be at higher
risk for heart disease and alzheimer's.
Um,
there's some murkiness there because
that's just on average,
you know,
we don't know if that,
that risk applies to people who are
eating,
you know,
paleo type of diet,
doing crossfit at taking care of
themselves in every other way.
We just know that,
that the general population in the
general population,
a higher ldl p leads to a higher risk of
these conditions.
Now,
I know pete,
I'm sorry to interrupt you,
but I know people,
um,
some people know this,
but some people don't.
What is the difference between ldl and
hdl and wise one good and one bad?
Well,
he asked,
here's,
yeah,
here's an example of how things are
changing again.
Um,
so historically the idea has been that
ldl,
which stands for low density lipoprotein
and hdl stands for high density
lipoprotein the ldl.
The idea was it was bad,
um,
has a number of effects that contribute
to the risk of heart disease.
Whereas hdl does a kind of like clean up
and repair process and actually reduces
the risk of heart disease,
but just a couple of weeks ago there was
some pretty influential research
published suggesting that hdl may not be
actually so protective and it may be
more of like a like a bystander effect
where people that have lower risks of
heart disease just just also have higher
hdl and it's not that the hdl is
protecting them.
It's whatever other underlying processes
are protecting them happened to lead to
higher hdl levels and the reason that
they think this now is that they.
They've done a whole bunch of trials on
drugs that raise hdl and guess what?
Nothing happens.
They don't need the people who have an
increase in their hdl because of the
drugs don't have a lower risk of heart
disease.
And in some cases they've even had to
stop the trials because it became clear
that there was not only no benefit but
maybe even some harm.
So what kind of harm would there be?
Just more know more cardiovascular
events or more deaths.
So it's just another example of
something that we just assume for so
long it's true.
And then we find out that it's not true.
I had a conversation with a guy who's a
brilliant guy and we were talking about
eggs and uh,
uh,
I said,
I,
I like to eat about four to six eggs a
day.
It was like,
wow,
what about all the cholesterol?
Yeah.
And I'm like,
wow,
you don't know.
And like you don't know that and you're
a really smart guy.
Like this is kind of stunning.
Yeah.
I mean it's.
And it's gonna take.
So,
so what I just told you about hdl,
think of everything that has to change
to reflect that new understanding.
You've got textbooks that need to be
rewritten.
You've got primary care guidelines
you've got,
it's just massive.
It's almost impossible to get our head
around.
And so the average primary care
provider's not going to get this message
for decades,
I would say decades,
not more than years.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
So they're going to be giving out bad
advice to people.
So the average person who works all day
and doesn't have the time to do the
research that you do or you know,
maybe isn't informed about all the
various blogs and books and just doesn't
have time,
goes to his primary care doctor and ask
him questions and he gets terrible
information because then unfortunately
the primary care doctor doesn't have the
time either.
You know,
they're,
they're in a bad spot.
You know,
I know a lot of primary care physicians,
they're all,
everyone I know went into medicine for
the right reason.
They're trying to help people.
They're doing their best,
but they're seeing 2,500
patients.
That's how many they have on their
roster.
Their average visit is eight,
is between eight and 12 minutes because
they get reimbursed based on the number
of visits.
So they,
in order to make a living,
they have to see a certain number of
patients a day.
And the insurance companies often
mandate that.
Um,
so in a 10 minute visit,
patient shows up with multiple chronic
conditions,
taking multiple medications,
uh,
and then presenting with new symptoms
that they're concerned about.
There's barely enough time to say hello
and you know,
figure out what's going on with their
meds and make an adjustment and make a
new prescription much less to talk to
them in any kind of meaningful way about
their diet and their lifestyle and their
behavior.
Forget it.
It's impossible.
So the,
the primary care doctors I think are as
much victims of the,
of,
of our conventional system and the way
it's set up as patients are and if
they're busting their butts,
seeing patients eight hours a day every
day,
and then they have all the paperwork to
do on top of that last thing they're
going to want to do is go home and fire
up pub pub mat and start reading,
you know,
the latest studies that have come out
for sure they're going to be exhausted.
Non-motivated.
Yeah.
And they got families,
you know,
they have other things to do.
And,
and,
and there are studies that have shown
that the majority of of primary care
physicians,
understandably given this situation,
receive most of their education from
pharmaceutical sales reps.
You know,
who bring in the brochures and to,
you know,
talk about a particular condition and of
course those are,
that's not going to be unbiased
information.
That's hilarious that they get their
information from that.
Wow.
Yeah.
Because the reps come to the office,
you know,
and so and they have the brochures to
the drugs and the in the brochures.
Talk about the condition and you know,
they have cartoons and pictures in there
and showing you the bad stuff that's
happening to your arteries.
It's crazy.
It's a crazy system and it's really,
it's,
we're in big trouble.
I mean that's the message in my book.
It's like,
you know,
this is not just about individual
health,
which is my first book was about taking
back your own health.
This book is about taking back
healthcare because we're,
we're screwed.
if you look at the numbers and by the
year 20,
40,
it's estimated at 100 percent of the
federal federal budget will go towards
medicare and medicaid expenses leading
nothing for anything else.
Military and just want someone with 20,
40 watts talking about our lifetimes.
That's real.
That's if,
if healthcare spending continues to
increase at its current pace,
that's insane.
You're right.
That does not.
This is why the department of defense's
has named healthcare as an existential
threat to this country,
just like,
you know,
nuclear war or any other military
threat.
They've named chronic disease as an
existential threat that could actually,
uh,
you know,
threaten our survival as a nation.
Wow.
Whoever thought of it that way,
who could have ever imagined that
literally all of our budget would go to
take care of people's health by 20,
40.
That's not long.
It's not long in.
Let me,
let me give you a few examples just to,
you know,
to make this more clear.
So the cost of treating a patient with
type two diabetes is estimated to be
$14,000
a year.
Okay.
So we know now that a hundred million
americans,
that's like a third of the population
have either prediabetes or type two
diabetes.
Yeah.
Wait a minute.
cdc just published these numbers.
100 million americans have prediabetes
or type two diabetes,
one third,
one third.
And that is the.
I'm having a hard time.
If you had just asked me like what
percentage of americans have diabetes?
I probably said like four percent
percent who actually have type two
diabetes is lower it,
but I said prediabetes or type two
diabetes.
Yeah,
so,
so here are a couple other sets.
A 88 percent of people who have
prediabetes don't know that they have it
at 87 percent and the average amount of
time it takes for someone to progress
from prediabetes to full fledged type
two diabetes is just five years.
Wow.
So let's go back to that number.
$14,000
a year to treat a single patient with
type two diabetes.
Imagine someone gets diagnosed at age
40,
which is totally possible.
I mean now even eight year old kids,
they're being diagnosed with type two
diabetes and imagine that person lives
at an another 45 years,
which is also feasible because we have
these.
One of the amazing things about
conventional medicine into the
technologies that keep us alive probably
a lot longer than we should be.
So let's say that person lives 45 years.
We spent $13,000
a year,
a $14,000
a year treating that person,
that's $630,000
to treat one patient with one disease
over that patient,
you know,
remaining lifetime.
Now if you start doing some math and you
assume how,
you know,
even 50 million people with diabetes
times $630,000,
you get a number with so many zeroes
after it.
I don't even know what it is.
It's like a google or a google plex or
something.
So this is why we're,
we're facing this threat and this is why
I wrote the book.
It's like people aren't aware that we're
at this point where,
you know,
like one in two americans now as a
chronic disease,
one in four have multiple,
one in two americans has a chronic
disease,
one into one in four have multiple
chronic diseases.
And I know you're a parent so,
and I am 2:30
percent almost of kids now have a
chronic disease and that's up from just
13 percent in 1994.
So there's been more than a doubling of
kids with chronic disease and less than
25 years.
How has that,
what has changed in the american diet?
YoU attributing it to the american
american and affects all of the above.
So I wouldn't say it's the diet,
It's an increase in sedentary activity,
you know,
lIke a sitting for very long periods,
not moving around,
not enough exposure to artificial or non
exposure to bright,
to,
to natural light.
Too much exposure to artificial light,
not enough sleep,
you know?
So all of these things come together and
now we've got a nation of people with
chronic disease and chronic disease is
bankrupting our country and it's
extremely difficult to treat.
It lasts for a lifetime and our only
hope actually of dealing with this
problem and surviving as a,
as a country,
as a nation,
is to figure out a way to prevent and
reverse disease instead of just
suppressing symptoms and putting
bandaids on it,
which is what our current conventional
medical system does.
Do you really scared me with that
diabetes number,
that debts really freaking out.
I can't believe that.
Well,
what do you pull them up,
jane?
More than 100 million americans have
diabetes or its precursor.
Staggering.
Cdc report reveals,
and this is just from july.
Yeah.
Wow.
In 2015,
least one point 5 million new cases were
diagnosed and people over 18.
Now a third of the us population is
diabetes.
Diabetes.
Let me throw a couple others that you,
uh,
the cdc just updated it to obesity
statistics.
Now,
40 percent of us adults are obese.
Oh my god.
Forty percent for intent,
not just overweight,
obese and 30 percent,
40 percent and almost 20 percent of
adolescents are now obese.
Now,
how are they based in this?
By those body standards,
body mass index,
obesity,
that it's not.
That doesn't work.
It's not perfect,
but it's not so,
so imperfect that it's,
you know,
we're talking about a 20 percent
difference.
Look at body mass Index,
five foot eight,
200 pounds.
I think I'm like dying.
I think like,
yeah,
like if you look at the body mass index,
I think I'm like,
have to have terrible health,
but all you have to do is go to an
airport.
You know,
I just flew down here,
you know,
you sit in an airport and you look
around yo the sticks or crowds,
but there's also a lot of people that
lift weights,
like there's a lot of people that are
bigger.
I would like to know what the,
you know,
what am I obese.
Yeah,
I'm obese.
Come on.
Damn that.
Come on site.
I mean look,
but you don't have diabetes and you're
not 10 percent body fat or.
Yeah,
so that's just not real.
That's not real.
It's not that.
Well,
I don't know.
I think that statistic.
I mean,
what do you think out of 10 people that
you see on the street are for obese?
Well,
if I'm obese now I know that I'm obese,
right?
According to that will give you gotta
throw that thing out the window.
That's not a good metric.
It's not a perfect metric,
but they have done studies where they
have accounted for that and they do.
You do see some variation,
but you're.
You're not the norm.
You're not,
you're not,
you're an outlier.
I'm aware of that,
but I think there's probably got to be
quite a few outliers out there.
There are quite a few but not enough on
ever,
but not enough to change that statistic
in a really meaningful way.
It's not going to,
you know,
there aren't 20 percent of you,
it's not going to drop that from 40
percent to 20 percent.
So maybe 40 to 35.
Is that reasonable?
Still a lot back.
Yeah,
that's,
I would say maybe 40 to 39 or 38.
Jesus.
Yeah.
So,
so,
so here's the deal,
you know,
uh,
we can't,
it doesn't matter who.
So that the whole recent healthcare
debate with the affordable care act and,
and then the current administration
suggesting something different.
That whole discussion revolved around
how we're going to pay for health care,
you know,
insurance,
health insurance.
But we have to understand that health
insurance is not the same thing as
healthcare,
right?
It's a method,
it's a method of paying for healthcare.
And my key point in the book is it
doesn't matter what method of health
that we use to pay for healthcare,
whether it's the government,
whether it's corporations or whether
it's individuals,
there is no method that sustainable in
the face of the rising rates of chronic
disease that we're seeing,
that there's.
There's nothing that would be
fascinating as I am pretty aware of this
stuff and I didn't know what you're
telling me and I'm stunned.
I'm stunned at the number of people with
chronic disease and I'm stunned at the
number of people that are either
prediabetic or diabetic.
I really don't know how to digest that.
That's,
that's horrific.
And that could be attributed almost
entirely to diet in a lack of extra sets
of preventable disease.
That's the crazy thing.
Type two diabetes is a fully preventable
condition in type one diabetes varies in
what way?
That's an autoimmune condition and it's
strongly genetically mediated.
So it's.
Which means that it doesn't necessarily
mean that if you have the genes you're
going to get the disease,
but there's,
you know,
50 percent of the risk I think is the
statistic that I've seen a of type one
diabetes is genetic.
Whereas we know now that 85 percent of
the risk of of disease in generaL comes
down to environmental and behavioral
factors.
Behavioral meaning you die,
yeah,
or or your sleep or your,
you know,
your physical activity,
stress management,
et cetera.
So that means only 15 percent of the
risk of disease is genetic,
you know,
purely genetically a driven.
Whereas the other 85 percent,
which is the vast majority is actually
under our control.
I was looking at a statistic that made a
correlation between sleep and weight
loss and saying that people who slept an
average of eight to 10 hours a day had a
significant,
a significant,
significantly less body fat and weighed
less and lost more weight than people
who did the exact same activity but
slept four to six hours.
Yeah.
I would say that among a people who
research a weight regulation,
sleep is now recognized as being the
second most influential lifestyle factor
that determines our weight aside from
diet low.
I had I ahead of physical activity,
so I got a couple of good ones for you.
A single night of sleep deprivation has
been shown to cause mild insulin
resistance,
even in healthy people with no
preexisting blood sugar disorders.
So just one night of not sleeping well
can cause a little bit of insulin
resistance the next day.
I mean,
it's transient,
it goes,
goes away,
but that's significant.
There was a study where they,
they deprive people of sleep for eight
nights in a row pretty severely.
It wasn't obviously not total sleep
deprivation because they'd be dead,
but you really be dead for eight nights
in a row.
I think so,
yeah.
I mean a partial partial but significant
sleep deprivation for eight nights in a
row.
these people ate an additional 566
calories a day,
um,
during that period with no changes in
resting energy expenditure.
So that's equivalent to gaining a pound
a week of bodyweight or 52 pounds in a
year.
So most people won't have that severe of
sleep deprivation,
but if you just even have mild sleep
deprivation,
you know,
over a significant period,
what if that could account for 10 pounds
of weight gain a year and over,
you know,
10 years,
you're,
you're talking about a lot of weekends.
Yeah.
So is it because you're sleepy,
so you just force yourself to eat food?
Like what?
no,
it just,
it totally screwed.
It totally screws with hormone
production and all the hormones that
regulate appetite and satiety and,
and things like that.
So his laptop and his tire and appetites
higher.
It's hard to get satiated and it also
decreases your willpower and judgment
around food.
So people are likely to make worse
choices when it comes to food.
I know I do.
yeah.
Do.
If I'm really,
really tired,
I immediately go to like bullshit
cheeseburgers or something.
Absolutely.
It's,
it's,
uh,
it's part of what has been documented
that happens.
yeah.
You like reward yourself with something
that's terrible for you.
Yeah.
Know probably in,
there's,
that's also related to the changes in
brain chemistry that happened.
So.
Wow.
Yeah.
And,
and now we know that a third of
americans get fewer than six hours of
sleep and outside of maybe three percent
of the population that has a gene that
allows them to,
you know,
be okay with that,
that few hours of sleep,
the vast majority of people need seven
to eight and a half hours of sleep to
function properly.
And that's been clearly documented.
Yeah.
I had read something about outliers in
terms of performance outliers.
There are a lot of people,
um,
that uh,
like entrepreneurs guys were killing it
out there.
They're,
they're getting like four to five hours
sleep at night.
And I was stunned by that and I was
like,
how's that possible account?
How are these people that are,
you know,
they're doing all these physical
activities working out,
running their business.
And then I found out about adderall.
Right.
So there's that.
Yeah.
I mean,
as I said,
there are some genetic polymorphisms
that we at least some research suggests
that allow people to,
you know,
deal with less sleep than others.
But yeah,
I think in that community there's a lot
of stimulant use.
It's driving that and at some point
they're going to pay the price.
Yeah.
They need to come clean about that.
Like that's the dirty little secret.
I have friends that are entrepreneurs in
silicon valley people and did the way
they describe it,
it's like,
like people chewing gum.
It's just everywhere.
Everyone is doing new vigil provigil
which are apparently less problematic
and then adderall across the board.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
I mean we're,
we're,
we're making choices now,
both individually and collectively that
are taking us in the wrong direction.
And you know,
the,
this,
this week I've shared a few stats that
kind of blew you away and they've blown
me away to,
you know,
when I was researching the book,
this is how it all came together.
For me it was,
it was like a wake up call,
you know,
so I have a six year old daughter and
now you have kids.
Today's kids are the first generation
that are expected to live shorter
lifespans than us,
their parents.
That's just crazy.
You know,
as long as we,
based on this statistic about diabetes,
the dramatic increase in chronic
disease.
So as long as we've been measuring it in
the modern world,
lifespans just been going like this,
you know,
there's been a few blips due to
pandemics,
like the spanish flu,
but for as long as we've been measuring,
it's just going up,
up,
and now this is the first generation of
kids.
It's actually expected start going back
in the other direction.
I showed my kids that,
that sugar documentary,
my wife showed it to them.
It lasted about four months and then
they will like,
who gives a shit?
Let's get back to the ice cream.
The kids,
it's not like it's hard because we're
hard that this is where the evolutionary
perspective is so important for people
to understand where we're hardwired,
to seek out foods that are calorie dense
and highly rewarding and by rewarding,
I'm talking about that term in the
scientific context context,
which means eating something makes you
want to eat more of it,
right,
so a potato,
chips,
ice cream,
highly rewarding because you'll keep
eating them even beyond the point where
your hunger has been satisfied.
A baked potato with no salt or butter,
not very rewarding.
You know you'll eat if you're hungry,
you'll eat it,
but you won't eat more than your hungry
for and even a steak which is most
people like and it's tastes good.
When's the last time you heard about
somebody bingeing on a steak?
It doesn't really happen because it's
not highly rewarding in that way,
but human beings evolved in an
environment of food scarcity,
so we have these wired genetic
biological mechanisms that caused us to
seek out foods that have a lot of
calories and that are very palatable and
rewarding because that would signal to
us that they have different,
different nutrients,
macro nutrients,
flavors,
et cetera.
And we're in an environment of food
scarcity that works really well because,
you know,
stocking up on calories would allow us
to survive a period of,
of,
you know,
famine or,
or food shortage or you know,
unable to locate food,
etc.
So we have all these mechanisms that
were originally designed to help us
survive starvation in a natural
environment.
That's all well and good when we're
living in that kind of environment.
But what happens when we live in an
environment where there is a seven slash
11 on every corner and amazon delivering
food your door and a costco around the,
around the block.
Food is everywhere.
And so all of these mechanisms that
actually helped us to survive in our
ancestral environment cause set us up
for failure in this modern food
environment.
And we capitalize on that with things
like the banana split.
Yeah.
Well the thing is that big big food,
they hire scientists who understand
these mechanisms and specifically
designed foods to hit all of those
circuits.
You know,
what do you think is like probably is
there a statistically most addictive
food?
Uh,
I don't know actually the answer to that
question.
I mean there's,
there's a lot of controversy about
whether sugar is addictive in the sense,
in the true sense of the way that
scientists use the term addictive like
meth.
Yeah,
exactly.
But,
And they're both sides of that debate.
Um,
but I think most of us can have,
you know,
just on our,
in our own personal experience can kind
of assess the effect that sugar has on
us or our kids or whatever it.
It's highly rewarding in the sense that
it makes us want more and more of it.
It's not addicted to me in the sense of
like I get a detox if I'm not having it,
but if it's around me and I wanted,
the craving is very creepy.
Right.
You know,
like what is this jamie?
Most addictive foods?
Pizza is number one.
Yeah.
Wow.
It's based on a health line.com
study.
I'll tell you what,
man,
this,
there might be something of that was
when we were in New York and uh,
you brought over those slices of pizza.
Goddamn,
those are good.
they couldn't figure out a way to make
that pizza here we have real problems.
Well,
it's interesting that you showed that
because I'm the top six foods in the
american diet,
according to cow,
the amount of calories that they
comprise in our diet or a pizza bread,
grain based desserts,
alcohol,
sugar sweetened beverages and chicken
dishes,
primarily fried chicken dishes,
like chicken nuggets from mcdonald's.
Those six foods comprise the majority of
the calories that the average american
eats.
And then you look at our ancestral diet.
It was mostly,
you know,
meat and fish,
wild fruits and vegetables,
not even the domesticated varieties that
we eat today,
nuts and seeds and a lot of starchy
fibrous plants,
um,
many of which aren't even available to
us at this point,
but,
you know,
sweet potatoes would be our kind of
modern analog of that.
And so you have a situation where we
evolved in the context of eating those
foods,
which are,
they're nutrient dense,
they're anti inflammatory and they're
naturally low in calories and they're
all foods that are very hard for us to
overeat.
Again,
like it's when you don't hear about
people bingeing on broccoli,
you don't hear about them.
Bingeing on steak,
you your money macadamia nuts,
man.
I yesterday,
last night I got home and I just had 14
sweet potatoes.
I hear about that.
And even if they have sweet potatoes,
a lot of times people put brown sugar on
them,
right?
Like maple syrup or something like that,
which then you might be,
you might overeat them,
but if in those foods in their natural
state,
we're not going to overeat them.
We're going to eat til we're satiated.
um,
but all the other foods that I just
mentioned,
those top six foods,
pizza,
grain based desserts like cake bread,
et cetera,
they're all foods that trigger all those
reward circuits in a big way.
And we've all had the experience,
I'm sure of overeating pretty or
overconsuming everything on that list.
I used to always,
uh,
coming home from jujitsu,
I would order an extra large pizza and
eat it myself.
It was this big,
it was huge and I would get,
I would get either pineapple and double
pineapple on double anchovies,
which I know some people think it's
disgusting,
but it's very delicious.
Or I would get a pepperoni and mushrooms
and I would kill that thing.
And then afterwards I would literally
feel like somebody opened up my mouth,
like they were trying to force feed of
goose to make fog fagua and they just
poured cement into my stomach and then I
just lay there and just feel terrible
and feel thAt insulin spike and your
whole body just reacts this sludge that
you're forcing it to process.
Just doe,
you know?
And she's.
And the cheese is great though.
Yeah,
I mean it's a step,
but it's that,
that it seems to.
The doe is what gives you that ball.
That's the heavy got bomb.
Yeah,
the gut bomb.
Yeah.
Why is it so good though?
Because I'll tell you what,
those alternatives,
they suck and that they're not that
good.
They're good food,
but they did.
Still,
there's not the same.
There's no free ride right there.
No decadent alternative.
Although I did find a very good cookie.
There's a company called no.
Do you know no foods and seeing that go
grab one of those things.
Yeah,
they have.
Oh,
we got one right there.
Yeah,
it's not bad,
man.
They're fucking.
No can dabble,
yada.
Yeah.
I mean I'm sugars like a s for the
entire cookie.
Twenty eight grams,
28 grams of sugar.
It's a big ass cook.
Yeah.
I see that.
And,
but
it's all like,
um,
and,
and I actually enjoy eating it,
but if you look at the ingredients,
it's all okay.
Here we go with almonds.
Coconuts,
egg whites,
flaxseed,
chia seed,
zero trans fat,
and a 16 grams.
Eighteen grams of protein,
four grams net carbs,
10 grams of fiber.
Yeah,
for a coupon and it tastes pretty good,
but it's not as good as not a large
pizza with anchovies and pineapple on
it.
Not as good as like a Mrs.
Fields chocolate chip cookie.
YoU know when you pull it apart in that
string of chocolate,
you know that absolutely.
I mean the nice glass of milk and those
are all good because they,
they,
like I said,
the trigger,
all of those hardwired reward circuits.
They push all the right buttons.
Yeah,
they get you.
It is amazing how many foods there are
that are like that.
If you stop and think about like just
going down the street,
walk in a normal street where there's a
bunch of stores and restaurants,
like how much of that stuff is bad for
you?
It's primarily bad for you.
It's primarily bad and you think the
whole modern food environment is that
way and that's what I mean.
We're set up to fail.
Anyone who said who sets out to be lean
and fit and healthy is swimming
upstream.
You have to be put in some serious
extra.
You have to constantly be putting in
effort because there's a barrage of
advertisements you walk into a grocery
store,
all of those foods are triggering all of
those circuits that make us seek and
crave those foods because those are
evolutionary mechanisms that cannot be
consciously overridden very easily,
and this is why weight loss continues to
be a billion dollar multibillion dollar
industry because information is not
enough for most people.
It's not enough just to know what foods
are healthy,
which foods are unhealthy because we're.
We're operating from a much deeper
system.
The olympics,
the limbic system are kind of lizard
brain that is driving our preferences
for food and what foods we seek in which
foods we don't see and that's below the
level of conscious thought that no where
we say,
okay,
I know that food's not good and I know
this food is good,
but then that lizard brain is like,
eh,
you know you had a delicious you.
It's almost like if you're walking by,
like if you have some potato chips or
something on the shelf and you walk by
it,
it's almost like there's an invisible
hand on your shoulder pushing you
towards you can.
You can kind of go hand.
I stop pushing,
stop pushing me,
or you can go,
all right.
Yeah.
You just kind of give and here's the key
thing to understand too,
that it's not because you're weak person
or you don't have willpower.
It's because you're a human being and
that's how your brain is programmed.
Yeah.
That is a very important thing to
realize that there's a reason why it's
difficult for you and and even for
people that think it's,
well,
it's not difficult for me,
man.
Well maybe if you've conditioned
yourself and if you've conditioned your
body and condition,
especially your diet,
there's something
that does happen when your gut biome
changes where your cravings change.
Absolutely,
but if you're eating a lot of sugar,
it is incredibly difficult to get off
that because that is what that gut biome
wants and there's some sort of a very
strange difficult to pin down feeling
that would.
That craving is.
It's very difficult to sort of
intellectualize,
right?
Like if you have to go to the bathroom,
it's very clear.
Oh my god,
I got to pee.
It's like there,
you feel it,
you know what it is,
but the weird hunger craving for sugar
is almost like you can't grab it.
You can't like hold on to and go,
this is what I'm talking about.
This is that thing.
Well,
there's the example I like to use.
there's a parasite that the whole life
cycle is really interesting.
You probably aware of it.
It,
it ends up in mice and it changes the
behavior.
Yeah.
Toxoplasma gondii changes the behavior
of mice so that they are dumber in terms
of their ability to evade getting eaten
by a cat.
Yeah,
and then so then they get eaten by the
cat and then the toxoplasma transfers to
the cat where and goes to the cat's
brain where it normally lives,
so that's an example of how a tiny,
tiny little micro,
but you can't even see with your eye can
powerfully control behavior and as you
just said,
we've got trillions of microbes in our
gut that control our behavior and things
like our food preferences and cravings.
We had robert sapolsky on the podcast
talking about that and he said that some
of the mice,
it actually rewires their sexual reward
system,
makes them attracted to the smell of cat
urine.
Right?
So their,
their testes swell and they're,
they're,
they're literally like horny little
zombies running straight towards the
cats.
It completely rewires their fear of cats
that goes out the window.
And the reason being is that the only
way that toxo plasma can reproduce is
inside the cat's gut.
Yup.
Which is just insane.
Like what kind of a twisted system and
how did this evolve over all these
years,
like the gut biome and gut bacteria.
It is so fascinating to me.
Here's a,
here's an interesting way of looking at
it.
Do you know justin sonnenburg?
He's a microbiologist at stanford.
Really fast.
Interesting guy.
Brilliant.
He,
I'm going to Paraphrase this because I
won't get the quote exactly right,
but he wrote a book about the gut
microbiome and he said something to the
effect of humans or are just the
elaborate elaborate vessels for the
propagation of microorganisms probably
right.
He's basically saying that we're kind of
the evolutionary vehicle or tool for,
for the microbes that live in our gut.
They've been around a lot longer than
us.
Um,
a lot longer.
They outnumber us,
you know,
the,
the number of microbial cells in the
body are more than the number of human
cells.
So there's lots of different ways to
interpret,
but I think
at the very minimum you,
you start to see how important that
microbial community is to our overall
health and also our behavior.
Yeah.
And if you really want to get creepy,
think about how like categorically they
don't vary individually,
like they're,
they're essentially the exact same thing
in mass numbers,
acting in the interest of the mass
numbers.
And then influencing us,
which vary widely and our different
actions propagate them in different
ways.
I'm freaking out.
It's especially weird too,
when you think that all of that stuff,
all of those microorganisms that are in
our gut,
they're not actually in our body.
So they're not really part of us.
They're just hanging out there.
Well,
think about a tunnel.
So you go through a tunnel under a
river,
you're not in the river,
woo.
You're just in a tunnel under the river.
And our gut is a hollow tube that goes
from our mouth to our anus,
intersects our body.
But everything inside the tube is
technically outside of the body.
So their influence,
they're influencing us from inside the
tunnel,
from inside of the tunnel.
They're not really inside of our bodies,
so they're kind of running the show,
but they're not really in us.
So it's like a car inside the tunnel
that's controlling the river.
Yet jesus christ more freaking out,
freaking out.
When I thought about that.
And the crazy thing is that they can
affect.
mood,
can affect,
depression,
uh,
your ambition,
the way you behave.
In a study on the way down here,
and I did a feed of all the new research
and it showed that overgrowth of
bacteria in our small intestine,
which is part of our got,
is associated with heart problems,
so it's,
you know,
and they don't actually know why yet,
but so,
so,
um,
you know,
something going on and with the cars in
the tunnel is really tweaking the river
and just about every way you can
imagine.
It's not just about gut as you know,
it affects every system in the body.
So paul was saying that one of the
people that he worked with found during
his residency that there's a
disproportionate number of motorcycle
accidents that were attributed to people
were infected by toxoplasma because it
made them more impulsive.
Right.
I can change human behavior as Well.
Yeah.
Well,
I think we talked about this last time,
but the prevalent theory now I'm.
What causes depression is that it's a
disrupted gut microbiome that causes
inflammation.
It,
it leads to the production of what are
called cytokines.
They're chemical messengers,
inflammatory cytokines.
They traveled across the gut barrier.
They go into the blood,
travel up into the brain and cross the
blood brain barrier,
and then they suppress the activity in
the frontal cortex,
which causes all the telltale signs and
symptoms of depression.
So what if depression,
which we have thought about either
as a,
you know,
disruption of brain chemistry or
something that's purely situational,
is actually,
uh,
you know,
has a physiological causes as a driver.
Now that's not to say that those
situational factors don't matter.
I don't want to be reductionist here and
say depression is only caused by gut
inflammation.
I think that's ridiculous.
But,
uh,
the problem is the average person goes
into the doctor with depression.
They're going to come out of that office
with a prescription for an
antidepressant.
There's not going to be any
investigation into their got and whether
they have inflammation in the gut and
intestinal permeability,
there's not gonna be a referral to a
gastroenterologist to,
to check that out.
And this is,
of course,
one of the problems with the
conventional system.
The way it's set up is we had a doctor
for every different part of the body and
there's no quarterback.
It's really overseeing that whole thing
that ideally that would be the primary
care provider,
but because their appointments are 10
minutes,
they've got 2,500
patients on their roster.
There's no time for that.
Yeah.
You'd have to find a doctor that's very
meticulous.
It's willing to go over your blood work
for you and check out what your diet is.
Yeah.
We'll take ours and wnl as they say,
we're not looking.
So imagine a patient that goes into the
doctor and they've got depression.
Let's say they've got a eczema or
psoriasis.
They've got a digestive issues and
they've got a brain fog,
cognitive problems like a whole big
roster of symptoms and the and the
primary care provider might give them an
antidepressant for the depression.
They give them a steroid skin cream for
the skin problem.
They,
you know,
they,
they leave with a handful of
medications.
But what if there was one thing that was
causing all these problems are one
underlying cause.
It was leading to all that.
So just,
you know,
in this example,
what if that patient had gluten
intolerance and they hadn't been
properly diagnosed?
We know now from the research that
gluten intolerance doesn't just cause
the gi distress,
a lot of people get,
it also can cause,
you know,
it's associated with dermatitis,
which is eczema.
It's associated with all kinds of
cognitive and neurological problems.
So a single food protein could be
leading to all of these different
symptoms.
But in the conventional system,
they might go to the primary care
doctor,
then they get a referral to the
dermatologist,
they get a referral to the
gastroenterologist,
they maybe get a referral to a
neurologist or a psychiatrist.
They're seeing all these separate people
to deal with all these separate symptoms
like,
you know,
playing whack a mole with the symptoms.
They take one drug,
uh,
the antidepressant,
but then maybe the antidepressant causes
constipation.
So then you go to the gastroenterologist
and they get a drug for the,
you know,
a laxative for the constipation.
And then before,
you know,
it's just this incredibly complex web of
all these drug interactions and,
and all the focus is on suppressing
these symptoms with different doctors
for different body parts.
When in this example,
at least it was something as simple as a
food protein.
It could be easily removed from the
diet,
maybe not easily,
but you know,
gluten's in a lot of things.
But I'm taken out and then all of those
problems which seemed like they were
separate and disconnected go away.
And that's really the promise of
functional medicine because instead of
looking at things,
starting with the symptoms and then
working backwards,
we're starting from the,
the,
the inside and,
and working out.
So,
you know,
an analogy I like to use is if you have
a rock in your shoe and it's making your
foot hurt and you go to,
into the conventional system,
you'll end up with a diagnosis of foot
pain.
Or actually we'll be fancier,
you know,
there'll be like the latin name for foot
and pain or something.
It sounds more official and you know,
and then you'll get a painkiller and the
painkiller will help,
you know,
it'll reduce the pain a little bit,
but obviously it makes a lot more sense
to just take your shoe off and dump out
the rock.
ANd that's really what functional
medicine is about now when it comes to
gluten intolerance,
that's one that gets dIsmissed as it
sounds.
It sounds frivolous,
like,
oh,
all of a sudden everyone's gluten
intolerant,
like this is crazy.
But my belief is that there's varying
levels of this and that it's something
that people have just dismissed,
is a weird feeling that you get after
you eat gluten and that they're not
really in tune with the effect of
inflammation and that there's a real
difference between the we'd have today
and the we'd have say the early 19
hundreds.
It's been maniPulated.
I think there are a few reasons.
There's misunderstanding about this.
Number one is that,
uh,
there up untIl recently has not been a,
an understanding of the difference
between celiac disease and non celiac
gluten sensitivity.
So for a long time the idea was either
have celiac or you're not sensitive to
gluten.
That's it.
I've heard that recently.
Yeah.
There's no gray area that's
preposterous.
Anyone who still believes that has not
even done the most cursory search of the
scientific literature.
you can go in and anyone who's watching
who's listening or watching can go to
pub med.gov,
pub,
med.gov
in the search field type,
non celiac,
gluten sensitivity or non-celiac wheat
sensitivity and tell me how many results
come up,
do it.
It's going to be a lot.
Okay,
and it's going to be linking and this
goes to the second point.
It's going to be linking not just to gut
problems and diarrhea.
It's going to link to all kinds of
different conditions from depression to
anxiety to heart issues,
to hormone imbalance,
to a cognitive problems,
etc.
So that's the second problem is
historically how many?
Six hundred and 50.
Jesus and I and and there's lots of
others.
If you use some different terminology,
you can find more.
So with celiac disease,
the initial idea was it,
it just causes diarrhea and severe
diarrhea and cramping and so the
assumption was that if you don't have
severe diarrhea and cramping when you
eat gluten,
you don't have celiac and you don't have
any other kinds of gluten intolerance,
but we now know that I'm there with
celiac.
There is,
if there are forums called atypical or
silent celiac,
these are forms that do not present with
the typical got presentation and the
number of atypical celiac cases out.
Not,
it's much higher than the number of
typical ones.
So a patient goes to the doctor,
they're having,
you know,
uh,
headaches,
they're having motor problems,
they're having a,
you know,
all kinds of other issues.
The doctor,
if they think that celiac is only about
gut issues and not even think about
testing that patient for gluten
intolerance,
what kind of motor issues would you get?
Well,
there was a,
there was something called a attacks
sia,
which is a form of paralysis that can be
caused by gluten sensitivity.
Yeah,
you can get paralyzed from the kids.
It's called gluten associated attacks,
ia,
jesus christ.
And this is for people who are non
celiac.
Yeah.
So,
so that's the second problem is,
is again w and l we're not looking.
So the patients go to the doctor,
they have all these weird kind of
complaints,
the doctor,
but they don't have gut issues.
So the doctor then rules out celiac or
non celiac,
gluten sensitivity because they don't
yet know that it can manifest in all
these different ways.
So how is this happening?
Is that the tolerance that you have for
gluten,
when you consume that gluten,
the gluten goes into the gut and
interacts with your gut biome.
And then what's the.
What's the mechanism?
There's two different mechanisms and
celiac.
There's an autoimmune mechanism where
the proteins in gluten,
the body creates antibodies towards
those proteins,
and also there's like a bystander effect
where certain tissues in the body that
have similar protein structures to
gluten get attacked as well.
Certain enzymes,
trans glutamates to transglutaminase is
three in trans contaminates,
six.
And here's the thing you knoW,
related to what we were just talking
about,
transglutaminase two is is is typically
found in the gut.
So that's why a lot of people who have
celiac have these gut issues is because
their body is actually attacking the gut
tissue and breaking it down.
It's an autoimmune reaction,
but now we know that trend there.
That same autoimmune reaction can be
directed at transcript tammany's three,
which is primarily in the skin,
which is why something like 30 percent
of people with celiac also have eczema
and other skin problems and trans
contaminated six is in the brain.
So this,
if you,
if a person who has antibody production
against trans contaminated sixth eats
gluten,
their body attacks their brain.
Whoa.
And that's why it breaks down the
enzyme,
which has played a number of important
roLes in the brain.
And so this is why celiac and also non
celiac,
gluten sensitivity is associated with a
whole bunch of different cognitive
issues like,
and also actual motor problems.
I a taxi because it's attacking the
brain.
The immune system's attacking the brain
and that leads to some potentially very
serious problems.
when did they start to alter wheat?
Like w what,
what year do you know?
I don't know and I do think that is an
issue because I've,
there's so many people that have gone to
europe,
you know,
they eat,
we eat here and they go to europe and
they can eat.
We.
Yeah.
Um,
but I think there are some other things
that are actually more meaningful and
significant and this leads me to the
third reason why I think we've
underestimated,
you know,
gluten sensitivity and why people don't
understand how significant it can be.
Um,
we're not living in a,
in a vacuum,
you know.
So let's say you've got a person who is
like a hunter gatherer.
They've been living in a pristine
environment,
you know,
they eat all nutrient dense,
good food.
Their gut microbiome is thriving because
they'd been eating plenty of fermentable
fiber and you know,
probiotic type of foods and they're just
super healthy.
If that person gets exposed to gluten,
they might not have any problem.
But then you take a person who is living
in the modern industrialized world,
they're sleeping five hours a night
there.
They've taken antibiotics,
you know,
30 but 30 courses of antibiotics by the
time they're an adult,
which is not an exaggeration that,
you know,
I can't remember the exact number,
but it's extremely high that the average
number of courses of antibiotics,
they were born by c section.
They eat a crappy diet with a lot of
processed and refined foods and they're
sedentary,
they're not exercising,
so this person is in really bad shape
and their immune system seriously
dysregulated,
and then when they get exposed to
gluten,
which might otherwise be a harmless
protein,
it causes problems.
So I think the reason that more people
are intolerant of gluten and intolerant
of other foods now is it's not just
because the foods have changed just
because we've changed is because we have
become compromised.
You know,
we should.
Human beings should be resilient and
able to tolerate these kinds of,
uh,
food proteins.
But when our immune system breaks down,
we talked about the gut as a barrier
system where everything that's inside
the guide is outside the body.
It's important to understand like in
that the purpose of the gut is to serve
as a selective barrier that determines
what gets in and what stays out.
Because everything we eat is either
absorbed or eliminated as waste.
And if that barrier becomes permeable in
a nonselective way,
meaning it loses the ability to make
appropriate decisions about what gets in
and out.
Then food proteins,
they would otherwise be benign and,
and,
you know,
be broken down into
smaller particles and those small
particles get absorbed and don't cause
any problems.
The larger food proteins get absorbed
before they're broken down.
And then that initiates an immune
reaction.
That wreaks havoc.
Wow.
So if someone has a healthy gut than the
insult of some sort of a gluten protein
being introduced into their,
god's not going to be as big of a deal
as if someone is just drinking gatorade
all day and eat and cook zygosity.
Uh,
that makes sense is,
it's like any other ecosystem.
So if you think of like an ecosystem
that's really healthy and you introduce
a predator like a predator or you know,
another,
something else that could,
could potentially throw it out of
balance,
it won't go out of balance because the
whole ecosystem is working together to
keep that in check.
But then,
you know,
you hear about like the small islands
where they introduced a particular,
you know,
a predator or prey species that then
just because the ecosystem of that
island is fragile,
you get a huge proliferation,
you know,
where it's just all of a sudden there's
nothing but deer on the island and until
they start dying because of that
imbalance,
you know,
and then it starts all over again.
So I've seen that before.
I've seen that in Hawaii,
on lanai,
right?
They're overrun With a,
an animal called the axis deer.
They're all over the place and for that
same reason,
and we have the same phenomenon,
like if we have,
if,
if someone's got microbiome is severely
disrupted especially.
And that started as a kid,
then they start,
they developed gluten intolerance,
they develop and tolerance to corn and
soy and dairy and allergy.
This is why allergies are on the rise in
kids is my belief.
It's not because there's some weird,
you know,
all of a sudden someone introduced some
kind of poison that is causing kids to
be more allergic.
It's because of immune dysregulation.
And that's happening because of the
sleep issue,
the food and all of the other aspects of
the modern lifestyle.
So what's the best approach for someone
who wants to be healthier if they want
to take control of their gut biome,
is it just consuming a lot of very
strong probiotic foods?
So the first thing is to just eat real
food.
I mean,
I,
I really liked boil it down to that
three words,
you know,
eat real food and by real I mean not
stuff that comes in a bag or a box,
you know,
the less processed and refined the
better and that either came out of the
ground or lives on the ground.
Right,
exactly.
And you know,
there are a lot of.
We tend to get really,
you know,
I'm worked up about all the differences
between,
you know,
there's [inaudible] you could say eat
real food and do vegan.
You could say real food and do paleo and
you know that that's all great.
But I really actually believe that if
people just ate real food of any kind,
we'd be in a totally different place
than we are now.
individual health issues would be worked
out in the variations of those dials.
Exactly.
That's where the fine tweaking comes.
But we didn't get to this point because,
um,
you know,
everyone's eating real food and
everyone's doing or everyone's doing
paleo.
We got to this point because people are
eating trash essentially.
So one of the most key things with the
gut microbiome to understand is that our
healthy gut bacteria thrive on what are
called fermentable carbohydrates or
justin sonnenburg,
who we talked about before,
he calls them microbiotic accessible
carbohydrates.
These are fancy terms that just mean
fiber.
So what,
what,
what distingUished is fiber is that we
don't break it down and turn it into
glucose or you know,
other molecules that we can absorb and
use for our own energy.
It stays in the gut to,
you know,
all the way to the colon and then the
bacteria eat that fiber.
so fiber is food for our beneficial gut
bacteria and that's what makes them
thrive.
so that's fascinating because most
people think of fiber,
they think of it almost as like a,
like a laxative.
Yeah.
I think it was something that's going to
clean out their bowels.
So not all fiber is fermentable by the
gut bacteria.
Some fiber just has that mechanical
effect.
It's more like,
you know,
pushing things through the bowels,
whereas other fiber can actually be used
as food by your gut bacteria.
And that fiber's probably more bats.
The more beneficial.
So you're talking like sauerkraut,
kimchi,
those.
Yeah,
there's soLuble fiber that are present
in a lot of fruits and vegetables.
Um,
you've got a non starch polysaccharides
like inulin and fos and things like that
that are in like onions and garlic,
jerusalem,
artichokes,
leeks,
umm.
And then you've got resistant starch,
which is actually not,
that's in a lot of starchy plants that
we used to eat,
you know,
way back in paleolithic era.
And some traditional hunter gatherers
still do,
but a resistant starch these days can be
found in certain types of starches that
have been cooked and cooled potatoes or
lentils.
Um,
some people now are supplementing with
resistance starch or they're eating a,
like green unripe,
bananas,
unripe plantations,
you know,
what are those?
Are those,
do that because they're unripe it's the
starches resistant.
As they ripen the starch,
it becomes just regular starch.
Um,
so cook those,
like if you wanted to cook a green
plantain use,
you can slice them and then dehydrate
them and you make them into chips.
You can even buy plantain chips now at
some health food stores by plantain
chips.
That's what you're getting.
You're getting dehydrated,
getting some resistant starch there,
uh,
or you can bake a white potato for
example,
and tHen let it cool.
AnD that cooLing processes what forms of
resistant starch.
And this is what's really interesting.
You know,
most people think of potatoes is
something that would spike their blood
sugar because they have a lot of
carbohydrate.
But when you cook and cooled a potato,
it won't have that effect because the
resistance starts,
you can't absorb and break that into
glucose.
Whoa.
So,
so when you cool a potato,
it's better for you?
Yeah.
So there's
like a cold potato salad would actually
not have the same effect on your blood
sugar is eating a warm baked potato that
you just cooked.
In fact.
Crazy.
Have you heard of the potato?
Heck no.
This is probabLy the most effective diet
that I've ever come across for weight
loss and this is what I use in my
practice with patients when nothing else
has worked or if someone's super
motivated and just wants to make
progress quickly.
A guy named tim steele introduced me to
this and it was a.
He has sent me some books that he found
in the 1880 [inaudible] that referenced
this diet.
So this is oLD schooL and what you do is
you basically eat nothing but potatoes
and you,
but you don't.
They're plain potatoes so you can roast
them or boil them,
but you don't,
you know,
in the hardcore,
the hardest core version.
You don't even add salt,
you just plain baked potato or boiled
potato.
I'm certainly no butter chives,
sour cream bacon,
you know,
because that increases the reward value
as we were talking about earlier.
The more variety there is,
the more rewarding of food is okay.
So,
um,
you just eat potatoes and there are
different variations or different ways
of doing it.
You can do it for maybe just three days
a week and then you can do your normal
diet,
you know,
the other four days a week,
uh,
tim talks about a variation called
potatoes by day,
which means you just eat potatoes for
breakfast and for lunch and then you eat
a normal dinner.
But I'm in my clinic and from tim's
experience working with a lot of people,
most people will lose an average of a
half pound a day.
And I think there are two there,
there,
there are a few things happening here
and why it works.
Number one,
uh,
it's,
it's totally playing towards these
mechanisms that we talked about before.
The,
the,
the reward,
the reward value food,
which is called the key donek system
that drives our food craving and
preferences.
And just,
let's do a thought experiment.
If you have two plates of food and on
one plate you have a steamed potato with
no salt or butter or fat of any kind.
And on this plate on the right you got a
bag of potato chips or just a plate of
potato chips.
Which one are you going to eat less of?
I mean it goes without saying,
right?
You're only going to eat the potato when
you.
When you're hungry and you're not going
to eat probably a bite more than you're
hungry for.
Whereas the potato chips,
all bets are off.
Yeah,
for most people.
And so what happens is when you do the
potato diet,
you get a spontaneous calorie reduction
and by spontaneous,
I mean not voluntary,
you're not setting out to say,
okay,
I'm only gonna.
Eat a thousand calories today.
You're saying I'm going to eat as many
potatoes as I want to satiate my hunger,
but just by definition,
because of how our brain works,
you're only going to eat.
You're going to eat less than you would
typically.
so that's one thing.
You get a reduction in calorie intake.
The second thing is that when the.
When you cook the potato,
most people,
the way they do this diet is they'll
just cook like you know,
all the potatoes that they need for the
week on sunday to make it easy.
So then I have to cook the potato every
time they sit down to eat,
so they cooked the potatoes and then
they let them cool and so then each time
you can still hit them back up,
um,
but,
but they now have a lot of resistant
starch.
Even if you heat them back up,
even if you hit them back up.
And here's what's really cool about it.
If you heat them up and cooled them
again,
each cooling cycle forms more resistant
starch so that by the end of the week,
if you've,
if you're heating all the potatoes,
backup and then cooling them again,
each time you're going to have a potato
that's mostly resistant starch,
which means it will have zero impact on
your blood sugar and it will be like a
feast for your beneficial gut
microbiome.
And that's another reason this diet
probably works.
We,
you know,
all about the studies correlating
disrupted gut microbiome with obesity
and diabetes.
And so you're basically,
the way I tell patients is you,
you're basically going on an all fiber
diet and you'll eat the skin too.
You can eat the skin usually discussion,
yeah.
Yeah,
yeah,
skin has vitamins in it so people will
lose up to a half a pound,
you know,
between a quarter and a half a pound a
day that they're on the potato diet.
It's amazing.
So if you,
let's say,
you know,
you decide I want to,
I want to lose one and a half pounds a
week.
You do it for three days a week and you
do that for six months.
Then by the end of that six month period
you've lost a pretty significant amount
of weight.
If you can keep that up,
keep it up,
the blend,
the it.
That's another fascinating aspect about
diet is like how much of our life we
were willing to forego health,
happiness,
all these different things just for some
simple mouth pleasure for a few moments.
Yeah,
I mean if you think about a pizza that
you would eat that.
I mean how long you need it for?
Twenty minutes,
20 minutes out of a 24 hour day and
you're going to feel like shit for at
least an hour or two afterwards.
You know,
if you try to do anything like physical,
it's going to be more than two hours
before finally if you really want to go
to the gym or you want to go for a run.
Oh,
and look,
I'm not saying I think everyone should
do this.
I think food should be pleasurable and I
think,
you know,
the way I eat,
for example,
I love the foods that I,
you know,
it's um,
but,
and this is why I say I don't suggest
that anyone wants to start here,
but I think it's interesting because it
gets it.
Some of what we've already been talking
about how,
why the modern food environment
contributes to obesity and how using
that knowledge and understanding of what
triggers us to eat,
we can turn that around and use it in
our favor.
So another strategy that's similar is to
just eat that but not quite as extreme
as jesus eat the same thing for
breakfast,
lunch and dinner for like two or three
days in a week.
So you get bored with it that way.
Exactly.
That seems like all mental tricks,
like someone would tell you,
like someone like jocko say,
just suck it up and being on there,
it's using our understanding of our,
our biology and our in our behavioral
mechanisms to,
to combat the way that the modern food
environment is working against us.
What do you think about like pre,
pre planned meal programs?
Like there's a lot of companies that
sell a prepackaged meal delivery
portioned.
Yeah.
That's not a bad way.
I think those can play a role too
because it's kind of a set and forget
kind of thing.
And you know what the portion size
should be.
Um,
there's,
there's another strategy that's very
simple that's been shown to contribute
to weight loss and,
and again,
it,
it plays to the same mechanisms which is
to get smaller plates.
So you know,
a lot you go to target and you buy
plates like this big,
right?
If it don't even fit in some of the
dishwashers.
Yeah.
Um,
and we don't even think it's just
something you wouldn't even think about,
but we have a tendency to fill that
plate up.
Yup.
And just for shooting a smaller plate in
any eating office,
smaller plates has been shown to have a
meaningful impact on weight loss.
Yeah.
Like you ever go to a buffet,
like when buffet always take some
obligation to,
to get your money's worth,
just gorge yourself bizarre combinations
of food that you would never put
together in any other context.
but it's all there.
it's variety is a,
it's a real problem.
Some people say is like the antichrist
for our,
the way our brain works with food
because it's variety.
It's all like highly rewarding,
you know,
palatable foods.
It's like the absolute worst possible
thing.
But if you think about it,
our entire food environment is,
it's like a buffet.
You can go into any store at any time
and get any kind of food to trigger any
of those cravings.
Yeah.
Do you supplement with any sort of
probiotics outside of regular food?
Um,
I will occasionally take probiotics.
I mostly try to get it through fermented
foods because I think that's probably.
What do you choose?
Sauerkraut is a great one.
Kimchi,
I do find with full fat fermented dairy
like kefir or yogurt,
sometimes we make our own yogurt for a
minute longer so it has more microbes
beat covas is a lesser known.
It's a beverage comes from Russia in
that area.
It's fermented beets and made into a
juice gust.
No,
you,
if you'd like some of these other
ferments,
I think you'd like it.
No,
I'm just joking around.
I like kimchi and most people think it's
file.
yeah.
Everyone in my house thinks it's vile.
Now the beak of us is good and it's
beats are super nutrient dense so.
And the fermentation brings out even
more nutrients.
So it's like a super food beverage.
Fermentation brings more nutrients.
Interesting.
Yeah.
In what way?
What did it makes them more
bioavailable?
Really?
Yeah.
What are,
what,
what nutrients does a fermenting?
Well,
uh,
from,
from fermenting creates a vitamin k for
example.
So fermented foods are wanting the best
source of vitamin k two,
and that's why a natto,
which is fermented soybean product from
Japan is the highest,
you know,
pound for pound,
ounce for ounce is the highest source of
vitamin k two.
There is that we know of,
but cheese is another high source of k
two and that's because it's fermented.
Um,
so most fermented foods have vitamin k
sit in beer or wine or any of the other.
I don't think so too bad.
Yeah.
Too bad.
Um,
so kimchi,
sauerkraut,
neto,
this beat stuff eat yogurt,
yogurt or a kefir,
which is like a liquid form of yogurt.
Um,
there are a kids kiss a certain kinds of
cheese.
Cheese doesn't tend to be as beneficial
in terms of the amount of microbes that
are in.
It will come up.
Gucci,
kombucha,
I love that.
And there's lots of different kinds of
kombucha.
There's also water kefir,
which is like dairy kefir,
but it's,
it's,
it's more like kombucha,
but it's used,
uh,
they used the kefir cultures to make it
a.
Every traditional culture almost has a
fermented food to it because our
ancestors understood even without
knowing the science that they were
beneficial.
How bizarre.
Well,
yeah,
they must've just trial and error right
now outside of that,
like what's a normal day in chris's
life?
Like as far as like your diet,
like what do you,
do you consume basically the same foods
all the time or do you mix it up?
Mix it up quite a bit.
Um,
lately I've been experimenting a lot
with quito and ketogenetic diet fasting.
I'm really interested in fasting right
now.
Um,
so like I haven't eaten yet today.
I just had coffee and some,
some cream,
which I do again,
I do find with full fat dairy,
I always do that lately.
I'm not always,
but I'm doing that a good solid four to
five days a week where I'm doing
intermittent fasting.
About 14 hours.
Yeah.
I feel great when I do and I,
I,
I love it.
I like the mental clarity and focus and
to be honest,
it's actually.
I mean I love food preparation.
I like to cook,
but it's nice to be able to have a break
from that,
you know,
not to,
not to worry about what I'm going to eat
and cleaning up and all that stuff.
And uh,
so,
you know,
these days my average day is kind of
like no breakfast fasting.
Then I might have a wet mark,
sisson calls a fat bomb salad for lunch
if you know,
if I have lunch,
I might have a later lunch.
Um,
so that would be like a salad with a
little bit of protein,
chicken,
fish,
et cetera.
And then like avocado and olives and you
know,
really good healthy fats.
And then,
um,
if I'm not doing a key to genic phase,
I'll have a normal dinner which would
look like a portion of protein,
lots of non starchy vegetable and like a
sweet potato or a plantation or uh,
uh,
some taro root or one of these paleo
friendly type of starches.
And if you were going quito,
how would you switch it up?
Then?
I would typically have the protein,
the non starchy vegetables,
and either like some zucchini noodles or
turnip noodles.
You can get like a spiralizer and make
the noodles really easily and I would
put some additional fat on those,
those,
you know,
vegetable noodles or I might just have
another non starchy vegetable along with
fat or a salad on top of.
You're essentially just manipulating the
fat levels.
other than that,
you're eating primarily the same type of
foods.
He just,
you're manipulating the fat versus
carbohydrate levels.
And how do you feel?
What do you find it difficult to
maintain the ketogenic diet and how do
you feel when you're on it versus when
you're not?
Yeah,
so for me,
because I'm leanne obviously the,
and I have a fast metabolism.
I can do quito for a couple of weeks and
feel pretty good.
I've done it for as long as three
months.
Um,
so I've done the full experiment and
what happens is after about two or three
weeks,
my exercise tolerance and recovery
starts to go down.
So I start to Have less capacity to Do
Like more glycolytic activities,
explosive movements,
weightlifting,
um,
even or sprinting,
high intensity types of training.
And um,
and,
and I start,
my sleep starts actually deteriorate a
little bit.
That's one of the biggest things.
So why would it be beneficial then?
What's beneficial about it?
Well,
I think so too.
Two things.
Number one,
not everybody has that response.
A lot of people just feel better and If
they're able to do it for a sustained
period of time and they don't have that
problem.
Number two,
I,
the way I'm trying to do it is kind of
replicating what I think was a typical
in the ancestral environment.
So,
um,
it,
most hunter gatherer cultures that we've
studied a would have naturally had
periods of food scarcity,
so they're not always starving,
but because they don't have a set with a
live and on the corner or costco or
whatever,
they would have periods where they
weren't successful in a hunt.
So,
you know,
they would go without eating or they eat
less.
That's just built into our,
our template I think.
And so I've,
I do a thing where I'm,
you know,
I'll do intermittent fasting for a
period and I might do a week or two of
ketosis and then I might just eat my
normal diet for six weeks or two months
after that.
And then I might do another week of
ketosis and I don't schedule it,
I don't plan it,
I just let my body tell me,
you know,
oh,
kind of feels like all I want to do that
now.
And are you doing blood tests?
are you doing breath tests?
How you monitoring your ketones?
I totally,
uh,
so I have the blood ketone monitor and
I'm from all the research that I've seen
at this point.
Breath ketone testing is not accurate at
higher levels of ketosis.
It's accurate at lower levels,
but when you get into the therapeutic
range around two point.
Oh,
one point five to two point.
which is kind of the sweet spot for me
than blood ketones are more accurate.
And the problem with the blood ketone
strips are super expensive,
especially if you buy them just like at
the drug store or something like that.
Um,
but,
uh,
I,
if you,
you can look around and try to find them
in bulk and they,
they're cheaper that way and,
and frankly at this point,
and I think that's true for most people
once you get used to it,
you know,
and you've done it enough,
you don't need to keep using them over
and over,
you just kind of know when you're going
to be in ketosis when you're not.
And I've tracked my,
my values and I've tracked,
you know,
I've treated hundreds of patients where
we've done these kinds of experiments
and this goes back to the discussion
about ldl.
So for me on a,
on a ketogenic diet,
you know,
if I measure my on my typical diet,
my ldl particle number is about $1,200.
So I'll just briefly describe what that
is because I think some people might not
be familiar with that.
So if you imagine that your,
your blood,
your blood stream is like a highway.
The cars on the highway or the ldl
particles and the passengers in the car
or the cholesterol that are carried by
the ldl particles.
So for years we've measured the,
the passengers,
the cholesterol inside of the particle,
and now most of the research suggests
that it's actually the number of
particles or cars on the road that is
the biggest driver of heart disease
risks,
not the amount of cholesterol inside of
them.
So you can measure this,
their labcorp and quest,
they all have a test panel called an
nmr,
um,
where you can measure the number of
particles that you have.
And so my normal diet is around 11 or
$1,200,
which is technically it's high normal or
you know,
in a kind of intermediate range.
I'm noT worried about that level.
Um,
but when I go to quito,
my ldl goes above 2000,
which is in the 99th percentile and,
and high high risk range.
Wow.
So this is where I was talking before
about getting to a point where we can be
maybe a little more personalized in
terms of the recommendations that we
make because not everyone who goes quito
experiences that,
you know,
some people do and some people don't.
What do you think that is?
Oh,
it's just the one that,
you know,
for me,
the quito type of diet,
um,
it,
it affects my liquids in that way and
know this is a much larger conversation
around does that actually increase my
risk of heart disease?
Again,
I said before,
we know that higher ldl on average in
the general population does,
but if,
if like let's say I have a doppelganger
know genetically identical to me in
everywhere identical twin and that one
is not eating healthy,
not exercising,
not sleeping,
not doing anything to take care of
himself,
and he has an ldl p that's high and I
have the ldl p that's high and they're
exactly the same.
Do we think that we're going to be at
the same risk of heart disease just
because that one number on the paper is
exactly the same?
That's the assumption that's made in
conventional research literature.
Right?
But I think almost anybody just common
sense would say,
no,
that's not true.
There are many other factors that
determine the risk of heart disease.
So getting back to this thing.
So for me with quito,
one of the reasons,
I mean the main reason I don't do it
ongoing is I don't feel well when I keep
doing it.
Like I said,
number two,
I don't like doing it long term and I
think that's important.
And number number three,
I don't necessarily want to have an ldl
p of 2000,
but you do think there are some benefits
to occasionally doing.
I think that it was very natural for
human beings to be in ketosis at least
part of the time.
And whether you enter into that by just
fasting,
um,
or whether you do it with a ketogenic
diet,
I don't know that that really matters.
I mean,
fasting has some additional benefits
above and beyond just ketosis,
like autophagy which is a cellular
cleanup and repair process that happens
in a fasted state.
Um,
if you think about it,
if fasting or being in a fasted state
was a normal part of human evolution,
it makes sense that certain processes
would only happen in that fasted state.
It does make sense.
But I would feel like when I'm talking
to you based on your experience,
I would avoid being in ketosis all
together because it sounds like it sucks
for,
you know,
it doesn't.
Those first two weeks are really great
and feel great.
Yeah.
And then it starts to shift over to dom
d'agostino said that there's like a uh,
so there's a,
an adaptation period.
Yeah.
Usually three weeks is the full period
for most people.
But like I said,
I've done a full,
you know,
longer experiments.
So I know it wasn't just a question of
me not being fat adapted.
I think he was talking about several
months in terms of like athletic
performance when you were performance
starts to.
Yeah,
I think that varies a lot from person to
person.
Also varies how quickly someone can get
into and out of ketosis.
I go into it very quickly.
For me,
just the second,
if I do one day of fasting or one day of
quito on the second day,
I'll generally be at one,
one point two,
which most people say is in a
therapeutic range.
And then by the third or fourth day I'll
usually be at two without a lot of
effort and deregulate your protein
intake when you're doing a ketogenic
diet as well to avoid the protein
converting.
Again,
that's highly individual.
From what I've seen.
For me,
protein doesn't seem to be that
significant of a lever.
I've tried,
you know,
I did an experiment where I was just
fasting in the morning so I had no
protein and then I would have three
ounces of protein only with the salad at
lunch and then I would have kind of
normal sized portion of protein.
So that's actually pretty low protein
for someone of my size.
Um,
and that.
And then I've done it where I've just
done quito where I've had protein for
breakfast,
lunch and dinner.
It doesn't seem to make a big difference
for me,
but I have patients for whom that's a,
that's actually as big of a leverage
carbohydrate.
And you know,
I had tom bill you on the podcast and he
was one of the founders of quest
nutrition and he said one of those quest
bars would knock them out of ketosis.
But just because of the amount of
protein,
I'm like,
that's crazy.
Yeah.
And I think they're only like,
um,
what is it,
like 18 grams or something,
somewhere in the range.
That's why it's a,
that's why it's so important for us to
get over this idea that there's one
approach that will work for everyone.
It's just stupid.
I know.
You know robb wolf,
have you ever seen robb wolf's
experience that he does on his instagram
and his wife?
They both eat the same thiNgs,
a totally different,
totally different results as far as
their blood sugar and his wife
metabolizes things far quicker than he
does.
It's really interesting.
That's really interesting because you
seem to people that lived together that
they're eating the exact same foods.
Yeah.
And uh,
and you know,
That he's so fascinated by it himself.
It makes an interesting too.
I mean it's,
it's so,
um,
it's so necessary for us to take that
step because you see so much like,
you know,
wasted energy in my opinion of people
arguing back and forth.
And it's often based on like,
you know,
joe blow goes on a low carb diet.
has a life changing experience and
becomes like a almost religious zealot
for the low carb lifestyle and assumes
that because it had that effect on him
that it's going to have that effect on
everybody else and,
and just starts proselytizing for low
car.
Yes.
Not recognizing that for someone else.
For example,
many of my female patients gone low carb
and,
and if,
if they're like,
you know,
working and taking care of kids and
doing crossfit several times a week,
you know,
that could be a disaster for them really
might not work.
And so,
um,
you know,
we just gotta we gotta take the next
step.
Yeah,
you have to take into account by a
diversity.
But uh,
there's a lot of people that dismiss
ketogenic diets because that's not what
they've been promoting.
That's a,
that's an issue as well.
Like you've gotta be real careful about
someone who's not citing actual science
when they're talking and dismissing the
ketogenic diet.
Like I read someone talking,
saying that it was a fad and it's hard
to get into ketosis that it rarely
happens.
I'm like,
well,
that's just not true.
That's actually factually wrong.
Yeah,
it's not hard at all and it happens all
the time and I've been in it,
I've done it many times.
I'm not in it right now,
but I do the same thing.
But for me it's a set of boredom.
Yeah,
I get bored and I want a peanut butter
and jelly sandwich or something and then
boom,
I'm out.
Yeah.
Well again,
I think that's,
that's probably closer to the ancestral
pattern of not being in a continually,
um,
but you know,
there are some people who need to be in
it continually,
like a ketosis can be a life changing a
intervention for a kid with epilepsy for
example.
And those kids benefit from being a deep
ketosis.
So they might actually even need
exogenous ketones on top of the key to
genic diet,
but they can go from having,
you know,
40 seizures in a day or being on like
just brutal antiseizure meds which are
horrible for kids.
I mean the side effects are so bad to
being completely off medication.
We can ketogenetic diet and so for them
that peanut butter,
they're not gonna have that sandwich
because it's going to cause
a seizure.
What was unique in my experience was the
cognitive benefits.
I was like,
this is really fascinating because I
felt so much more clearheaded and from
the fog of refined carbohydrates,
but I think that that is a.
I don't know if it's the same or very
close if I just follow a low carb diet,
not necessarily ketogenic,
but eliminate refined carbohydrates but
don't eliminate salads or fruit or
things along those lines.
Like if I want a pair,
eat a pear,
you know what I mean?
But the very strict application of it.
One of the first immediate things that I
recognize is that my hunger is a very
different thing when I'm hungry,
it's not that big a deal.
WhereAs when I was eating a large amount
of refined carbohydrates,
the hunger was ferocious.
Yeah,
yeah.
It was almost like,
like overwhelmed,
like drums playing in the background
and that's the ketones because the brain
can utilize.
Ketones may even prefer key to glucose,
and so when you're producing those
ketones,
it really does take the edge off of
hunger and it also fuels
brain in an odd way.
I mean,
I find that before I do difficult tasks,
mental tasks,
I like to drink exogenous ketones,
ketones,
I like to take them.
I think you're actually like it though.
Yeah,
I do.
I don't mind.
Yeah.
What does that stuff,
janice?
Oh yeah.
I liked them the best.
It doesn't taste bad at all.
I drink it before I work out.
I like those.
Yeah.
I don't think they're bad.
You know,
and I throw some alpha brain in there.
I just shake it up and it actually
tastes pretty good.
Yeah.
I think there's definitely a role for,
for the ketogenic diet and for ketosis
in general and you know,
fasting,
as I mentioned before,
had some really interesting benefits
above and beyond ketosis that I've been
exploring a lot might work with
patients.
Um,
have you heard of the fasting mimicking
diet?
No.
Doctor valter longo.
so,
uh,
dr longo was at usc center for longevity
superstar scientist and he basically
came up with this approach to get,
you know,
the idea was to get the benefits of
fasting without doing a full water fast.
And so it's a reduced calorie diet for
three that's done for three to five days
with specific macronutrient ratios.
And he's done some really interesting
research.
Most of it is an animal,
so you have to,
you know,
take that with a little bit of a grain
of salt.
But there has been some in humans as
well.
And it's shown things like in animals
with nms,
just doing this,
fasting mimicking diet has lead to
regeneration of the myelin sheath and
which is what breaks down in ms,
which is just,
you just don't see that,
you know,
no animals got,
there's no dre will they have animal
models of ms where they created an ms
light condition in the animal in order
to study it.
Um,
and they show,
they've shown changes in the brain.
You know,
we're actually that read growing.
And,
and the reason for this,
this,
it's thought is that this fasting can
promote stem cell regeneration so you
can actually through fasting,
rebuild certain parts of your body
according to this research.
So,
uh,
and then there was the autophagy which I
mentioned before which is like almost,
you can think of it as like a cellular
recycling or clean up or repair process
that happens in that fast at state.
And so if you look in the research
literature,
it's really fascinating because they're
more older,
you know,
older studies.
There hasn't been as much research until
recently on fasting,
but fasting has been shown to be a cure
for all kinds of different conditions.
Like,
you know,
severe rheumatoid arthritis,
patient can fast and then be completely
symptom free.
And of course they can't keep that up.
You can't just fast forever.
You obviously will die.
But that alone tells us something
interesting about fasting and about food
and how food is impacting those
conditions.
Yeah,
that is absolutely fascinating.
I'm the consumption of carbohydrates.
Dom d'agostino put something up about it
recently,
a low sugar and carbs that they're
closer and closer to connecting sugar
and carbs to cancer.
This is a pretty controversial area and
I'll say right off the top that I don't
consider myself to be an expert.
Um,
so,
uh,
you know,
I'll probably just pass on this,
but I think there's certainly enough
research pointing in that direction to
continue to look at that and they're,
you know,
even he probably talked about this,
but drugs like metformin which limit the
availability of glucose are being
studied even by the nih,
you know,
very traditional mainstream scientific
organizations as a therapy therapeutics
for cancer as is ketogenic diet,
dom studying non and others are as well.
Um,
but I think it'S a little too early to,
to,
to say that all cancer is caused by
high,
high blood glucose level.
The antibodies saying,
all right,
I think they're,
they're saying there's a strong
correlation between the two.
Now when you look at the overall
american diet and the number of chronic
diseases and all the different various
things that we have,
and you correlate all these factors,
when you think about sedentary
lifestyle,
you think about the lack of sleep,
and then of course you think about diet
and exercise.
Um,
when do you think people are gonna
recognize or how do we get people to
recognize that what they're eating and
what the average person is eating is not
what the body's designed for.
And this may very well be what has
triggered this whole cascade of effects.
That's the trillion dollar question,
literally trillion dollar question
because we spend three point
$2,000,000,000,000
on healthcare a year.
Um,
so,
you know,
I,
I think there's an easy way in a hard
way to get there.
So the easy way is that we continue to
raise awareness through books and,
and things
like this.
And you know,
um,
we,
we make proactive changes to the
healthcare system that support the most
important intervention.
So let's use an example again,
I'm imagine it so,
so you go into the doctor right now,
let's say you're one of those 100
million people that has,
you know,
type two diabetes or prediabetes and
they,
they test your blood sugar,
they say your fasting glucose is 96 joe
and your hemoglobin a one c is five
point five.
Good news.
That's normal.
Well,
yeah,
okay.
It's in the normal range but it's in the
high end of the normal range in the
current system.
They'll just tell you it's normal.
They might maybe maybe not make any kind
of dietary recommendations and then send
you on your way.
And the idea is we're not going to pay
attention to this until it's not normal.
You know,
we're not going to pay attention to this
until you actually do have prediabetes
or diabetes.
And um,
so the,
wait until you have that.
And then of course the longer that you
wait to treat it,
the harder it is to reverse.
And then you.
And then when,
when,
once they do find that you have it,
they just give you a drug rather than,
you know,
give you any kind of real support to
make diet changes.
So even if the doctor is,
it does know what to do or what to tell
you about diet,
which they often don't because they just
don't have a lot of training in that
area.
And it's also how few people really have
the contents of their body analyzed.
How many people actually get blood work
done,
right?
Well,
I'd say 80 percent don't even know they
have prediabetes,
but let's assume that they do and let's
assume they get to the doctor and let's
assume the doctor even knows what to
tell them.
Right?
If they tell them that are they,
does that gonna be enough to make that
person successful in changing their
diet?
And especially not if their gut biome is
program to crave that sugar and they
have low willpower especially,
they get very little sleep at work all
the time.
All those factors,
those factors.
And we know they like most importantly,
information alone is not enough to
change behavior.
We,
I said that before,
that's well established scientifically,
Just telling someone,
hey,
you should eat a healthier diet.
You know,
one percent of people are going to be
able to retake that information and act
on it successfully,
especially over the long term.
But let's imagine a different scenario.
Let's imagine you can go into the
doctor.
Same thing.
They test your blood sugar.
It's,
you know,
high normal fasting glucose,
high normal agency,
and they sit down,
they say,
look,
joe,
and this is obviously happening in an
appointment in this longer than eight
minutes,
right?
They sit down,
they say,
well,
you're not prediabetic yet.
um,
but your blood sugar's starting to creep
up.
And I'm worried that if we don't do
something now,
you're going to get,
you're going to become prediabetic and
eventually diabetic.
so,
you know,
I could give you a drug,
but that's just putting a bandaid on the
problem.
So what I'm going to do instead is I'm
gonna hook you up with our health coach
and nutritionist and she,
he or she is going to create a recipe
for you meal plan.
They're going to come to your house.
They're going to clean out your pantry
and get up,
get rid of all the bad foodS.
They're going to go shopping with you
and show you actually exactly what you
need to buy.
They're going to help you set up these
meal plans and give you recipes so that
you know exactly what you should be
doing or they're going to set you up
with this meal planning service that we
work with and I'm also gonna set you up.
You're going to get a gym membership and
you're going to get set up with a
personal trainer at that gym and so that
you can start getting,
you know,
becoming more physically active.
We're going to give you this,
a online class that talks about sleep
hygiene and how to get better night's
sleep.
It's a six week program.
You do it for half hour a day,
no problem.
And here's the good news,
joe.
This is all going to be covered by your
insurance.
You're not going to have to pay for any
of this that you know.
That is totally possible.
And not only that,
is there any doubt that if even if we
spent $10,000,
let's say,
which is more than that would cost even
including the health coach and the fees
for the gym and the fees for the
personal trainer.
If we spent that amount of money right
up front,
we could put that per get that person's
blood sugar back to normal level,
prevent them from ever getting type two
diabetes in the first place,
give them way more confidence in their
own ability to take care of themselves
and prevent disease,
make them feel better and probably every
other way and save the healthcare system
$640,000
over the next 45 years.
We could have that.
There's nothing stopping that from
happening.
The real question is how do you get
someone to act?
That's the question.
That's true.
Inspiration.
I said with the health coach so that
it's not actually.
I mean this is well defined.
We had.
There's so much research on behavior
change and evidence based principles
that support behavior change.
So there there are techniques like
motivational interviewing,
coaching to strengths.
I'm a coach into strengths.
Yeah.
So that,
that means helping people identify and,
and work with their strengths rather
than trying to fix what's broken.
Um,
motivational interviewing is what would
be an example of that.
Let's you have a person works a regular
normal job and they've got a big gut and
don't want to lose.
We have a,
you have a,
it's shifting the focus around from
what's wrong,
which is really disempowering.
Like I can't do that.
I'm,
this way.
I'd have no willpower or whatever to
helping them become aware of certain
personality traits or characteristics
that they can then use to make the
change that they want to make.
Motivational interviewing is like this.
Imagine a woman who's 55,
you know,
finds out that she has type two diabetes
and the doctor's like,
you should eat a better diet and she's,
she would like to,
but she's overworked and tired and it
feels overwhelming and,
and she's just not really finding the
motivation to do that in this,
you know,
but she has grandkids.
She loves her grandkids.
She wants to see them grow up.
She wants to be able to play with them
without becoming blind and immobile from
type two diabetes and so the the per the
health coach is trained in motivational
interviewing,
can help her help that,
that patient to be able to tie that,
those deeper values and goals and
motivations with the health goal so that
it's not just eating a healthy diet for
the,
for the sake of eating a healthy diet,
it's eating a healthy diet because I
really want to see my grandkids grow up
and be able to play with them.
OkAy,
so and then there are these principles
of behavior change that are,
that are totally well established.
So one is shrink.
The change is a colloquial way of
putting it.
Like let's say you're going to start a
meditation practice.
The way to not do it is to say,
okay,
so start doing that.
Do an hour of meditation a day.
Good luck with that.
You know,
that's gonna fail in 99 point nine
percent of the cases.
The way to do it might be,
okay,
step one,
not even that step one,
download the headspace app on your
phone.
That's it,
that's your first step,
you know,
step two,
but get a meditation cushion.
That's it.
Step three,
you know,
open the headspace app and do your first
two minute meditation.
I mean,
the headspace app is actually built in
this way where they start,
you very small and you build up
gradually over time because they know
about those principles of behavior
change.
Uh,
we know that behavior change works
better in community.
Um,
this is,
uh,
this is a head spinner to obesity.
Some people have argued is a contagious
disease because people who have friends
that are obese are more likely to be
obese themselves.
You know what,
that,
that makes a lot of sense.
And,
uh,
here's an example of something,
one of the reasons why that makes a lot
of sense.
Uh,
we just did this thing sober october me
and uh,
yeah,
and our shaffir tom score,
bert kreischer and I,
we took 15 hot yoga classes,
no booze,
no weed for a month,
but because we were doing it all
together and we kept checking in on each
other,
it was very motivating and um,
and no one's strayed and we all were
doing it too.
We knew that we had,
we had all,
we had a responsibility,
we have responsibility to the group and
that we,
we knew that we're motivating each other
as well as pushing each other and
talking shit to each other and making
fun of each other,
which is what we do nationally.
But at the end of it we were like,
wow,
that was great.
like there's something to that.
Like a lot of us were like,
I'm never doing yoga again for yoga and
I'm getting drunk for a week.
but the real takeaway from it was there
was some measurable motivation and
inspiration from having three friends
doing it with me.
Absolutely.
And that's again been improving in the
science and even just having one person
like a health coach who can play that
role and be accountable,
they can help you get in touch with the
real motivation for doing it.
They can actually design a program for
you that's life likely to succeed
instead of fail or perhaps online
groups.
There's got to be online groups to get
involved with.
We have the knowledge and the technology
to do this.
And it's not,
It doesn't take a long time.
You can retrain a health coach in six
months or a year.
They don't need to have nine years of
premedical,
you know,
traIning and biological sciences and all
this.
They just need to be trained in behavior
change.
You know,
they need to be people who can form a
good relatIonship with somebody else and
build that trust and rapport.
They need to have some knowledge,
of course,
of diet and lifestyle and stuff.
But like I said,
imagine that you go into your doctor and
they actually hook you up with someone
like that who has all that training.
Um,
if you think of how the healthcare
population as like a pyramid,
yeah,
at the top of the pyramid you've got,
you know,
people who are really sick and who were
in the hospital or in some kind of acute
care setting,
they absolutely need intensive support
from the conventional medical system.
Then you go down,
you've got another 25 percent of people
who have some kind of pretty
debilitating chronic disease where they
need to be seeing a doctor regularly,
but then in the bottom 70 percent you've
got a lot of people who are just
overweight.
They're tired,
they're not sleeping very well.
They got some gut issues.
They got some skin problems.
I.
My argument is that those people can be
really well served by well trained
health coaches and nutritionists who can
work intensively with them on diet,
lifestyle and behavior change and we
know that those changes are the single
most important step we can take to
prevent and reverse disease.
But we also know that just telling
people about it doesn't work.
You have to create that support system.
Well,
our whole food system is so crazy
because it's so fraught with peril
everywhere you go.
It's a goddamn minefield.
Exactly.
You're trying to eat a healthy diet.
You have to go way out of your way to
find what you can consume.
Oh,
there it is over there.
Whereas if you just want to eat a shitty
diet,
it's everywhere in front of you.
The the vast majority of the food that's
available to us is not healthy.
Yeah.
I mean if,
if you took somebody from our culture
and drop them into like,
there's this group called the cmo manet
and Bolivia.
They're a hunter gatherer group that's
still follows their traditional
lifestyle.
if you took someone from here,
drop them in there and just made them
live that way,
they'd get healthy because they wouldn't
have any choice.
You know,
they would eat what was there and
they'd,
they'd be living outdoors and they
wouldn't have ipads.
They're staying up and looking at it
until two in the morning and you know,
they would be healthy,
but likewise they'd get killed by a
jaguar or they'd get.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's definitely possible,
but if you took one of those people and
you drop them into here like woodland
hills or New York city or san francisco
or anywhere else,
is there any question that what's going
to happen?
They're the same exact thing that
happens to all of us in this,
in this modern.
Well,
we've seen that with the nun when the.
When the nun.
One of the more fascinating things about
studying the nun was how small the
number of people
that got cancer was such an incredibly
small number and they essentially had no
vegetables.
They were eating fats from seals and
wail and whatever.
They could consume.
Extremely limited diet environment.
Yeah,
very harsh environment and.
But they had adapted to it and then when
western America came into their lives in
terms of like cigarettes,
shitty food,
alcohol,
refined carbohydrates,
cancer rates
through the roof,
just through the roof.
Which is fascinating because their jeans
hadn't changed.
Absolutely the same genes.
They're not going to change in one
generation or even two or three.
Yeah,
it's,
it's horrible.
Have you seen west and price?
You familiar with his work?
I know the name,
so it was,
he was a dentist back in like the 19
twenties and thirties,
and he wrote a book called nutrition and
physical degeneration.
And what he as a dentIst,
his main interest was why did,
why did so many cavities,
that doesn't seem natural,
right?
It doesn't seem normal that were
designed to just develop rotten teeth.
You thought this is stupid.
So I'm going to go around and study all
of these traditional cultures all over
the world.
And first I want to find out do they
have cavities and dental decay and,
and like a narrowing of the dental arch
and changes in facial structure that we
have in the industrialized world.
And the second question is,
if not,
what is the common element,
you know,
with all of these cultures,
it's different than our culture.
And in his book he shows pictures.
So first of all,
the answer to the question was,
no,
it's not normal for humans to develop
cavities and rotten teeth.
I mean,
how could it be?
How could we survive in the natural
world if our teeth are all falling out?
Um,
so he,
he went and he took pictures of these
people all around the world,
like in africa,
the,
my side,
a hunter gatherer,
people,
uh,
people living in a remote part of
Switzerland,
isolated up in the hills that had
maintain their traditional diet and
lifestyle and all of them had these
beautiful teeth,
big wide round faces,
dent,
you know,
wide dental arches,
all of these signs of health.
But he also in the book had pictures of
people from those same areas that had
switched to move to the city,
you know,
switch to modern lifestyle within one
generation.
You see people with these wide faces,
big healthy teeth smiling on one side of
the page.
And on the other side of the page you
see people with these narrow faces like
mine,
uh,
you know,
rotten teeth,
totally it's crooked teeth and the kind
of dental problems that we all have
where most of us get braces and all this
stuff.
And that happened in just one generation
of switching from a traditional diet to
a modern either faced then,
uh,
so vitamin k two and,
and a lot number of vitamins are
responsible for facial development.
So if you,
uh,
if you look in the book of a western
prices,
um,
pictures,
you see most people
in the,
in,
in those traditional worlds have these
broad,
healthy dental arches.
And then,
uh,
in our culture because of nutrient
deficiencies and we're not eating the
healthy nutrient dense foods are faces
get more narrow,
our chins received,
we have our mouths become more crowded,
which is why many people can't fit the
number of normal adult teeth in their
mouth because they're dental arches so
narrowly.
So that's all from that nutritional
deficiencies.
Absolutely.
Why I had to get,
I had to get adult teeth pulled when I
was a teenager because my mouth didn't
have enough room for all of my adult
teeth.
Does the rest of your family have
similar facial structure?
Um,
yeah.
Largely.
Yeah.
I mean,
you can check this out.
It's really interesting things to do in
the airport.
I liked it,
you know,
you just look at people's faces.
Often you'll see like the chin is really
receded and not,
you know,
not like a strong,
you'll see in a narrow face like mine.
Um,
and if you,
you might see a,
a person from africa or someone who's
more connected to their traditional diet
lifestyle,
they'll typically have a rounder face,
a more full face,
broader dental arch.
They'll have straight teeth with wider,
wider teeth.
And you can,
you can,
anyone can do this.
Anyone can see and look and you can
almost predict how long has that person
been away from their traditional diet
and lifestyle.
Wow.
I never knew that.
You know,
that's a fascinating point.
It's a big variable in martial arts and
the ability to take a punch.
Well your face is,
it's pretty round.
You have a broader,
but it's not just what you're eating is.
My mom is very wide.
Have a thick mom spiLling pit bull.
Yeah.
Well it's probably part of why you're
probably a good performer is that you've
got that structure that supports it.
Yeah.
I'm sure it has something to do with it
genetically.
Um,
but the,
the ability to take a punch is I think
directly related to the size of your
face.
Yeah.
Guys with smaller jaws and smaller
faces,
they have a much harder time getting
hit.
I wouldn't last long.
Well,
like samoans are the best at it.
Yeah.
It was just such a pro.
For example,
instruction.
Weston price has a lot of pictures from
people in the south pacific and that
region,
you know,
examples of these beautiful.
You should check it.
You would love the book.
It's really amazing to see the
juxtaposition of those traditional faces
with the modern ones.
It's like you,
I mean,
a picture's worth a thousand words,
right?
You just look at those pictures and
you're just like,
oh my god.
TotallY makes sense.
Yeah.
It is a very weird.
When you think about what we're doing to
the human body and when you're talking
about the diabetes levels that you're
talking about,
or prediabetes and chronic disease and
all the different issues and 40 percent
obesity rate and the all these different
factors,
it's an epidemic that's sweeping through
the entire nation and it's largely,
other than health fads,
a weight loss videos.
It's like peripherAlly examined.
I like to call it a slow motion plague.
Whoa.
Because like the bubonic plague,
you know,
which was a fast motion play.
It threatens us in the same way.
Like it's literally threatening the
health of future generations.
It's shortening our lifespan.
It's destroying our quality of life.
It's a big one.
Yeah.
And if you stay alive,
the quality of life is being devastated.
Or as a recent article that came out
saying just that,
like is it was,
it was,
it was a paper that looked at,
um,
what's happening in our older years and
saying,
yeah,
we have a long lifespan,
but our quality of life has
significantly declined in those later
years because we're burdened by all of
these chronic diseases.
You know,
the average Something like a one in five
are two and five elderly people over 65
are taking more than five medications.
It's a huge problem.
And this is the thing you hit on this
point,
so I want to reiterate it because it's
super important.
We have accepted chronIc diseases,
normal because it's so common,
but there's a really important
difference between common and normal.
What's common is,
you know,
it's not necessarily normal,
it's now,
it's now common for people to have
chronic disease,
but that's not normal.
How do we know?
Again,
the tsimané that's a.
It's a subsistence farming hunter
gatherer population in Bolivia and
recently there's been some articles in
the New York times about them.
This,
some anthropologists,
medical anthropologists who've gotten
and doctors and researchers have gone
down there to study them.
They wanted to see that.
It's like this is one of the last places
on earth where people are still living
pretty traditional diet and lifestyle,
so we better study this quickly,
you know,
to see what's normal,
what's truly normal for humans.
Not common but normal.
Yeah.
So they eat,
you know,
paleo type of diet.
You know,
fruits and vegetables,
some meat and fish,
nuts and seeds,
some plantings,
other kinds of starches.
They walk an average of 17,000
steps a day,
which is about eight miles.
So quite a bit.
They live in sync with the natural
rhythms of light and dark.
You know,
they don't have a lot of artificial
light exposure like we do.
They sleep seven,
eight hours.
In fact,
the researchers are trying to ask them
about insomnia.
They didn't even have a word for it.
And their language,
they work.
Yeah,
they,
you know,
they're living their normal normal.
That's as closest we're going to get to
a normal human population.
Right.
So they studied,
they studied,
um,
they,
they did blood markers on them for heart
disease,
but not only that,
they did scans ct scans of their heart,
you know,
the cfa had calcification of the
arteries and they found that the rate of
heart disease in this population was 80
percent lower than it was in than it is
in the us.
Eighty percent lower.
Okay.
Nine and 10 to manet adults that they
studied had absolutely no plaque buildup
in their arteries,
which means they have virtually no risk
of a heart attack as far as we
understand it.
And you know,
before anyone who's listening to this
says,
oh yeah,
that's just because hunter gathers all
die when they're 35 years old.
you know that familiar argument.
Well,
this study included people between the
ages of 40 and 94 years old.
What's more,
tHe researchers estimated that the
average simani 80 year old had the same
vascular age as an american in his mid
fifties.
Whoa.
There's no almost no cognitive disorders
or alzheimer's disease in the
[inaudible].
So that's a really clear example of what
happens when you give human beings the
right inputs and they're not exposed to
all this crap that we're exposed to.
They live long and healthy lives that
are virtually free of chronic disease
and that's despite the fact that they
have much higher rates of infection than
we do.
They live on a river,
they've got parasites galore,
like all of them have parasites.
Yeah,
and yet they still are healthier than us
in almost every way you can measure it.
They have lower body mass index,
lower blood pressure,
lower weight.
They don't get heart disease.
They don't get alzheimer's and dementia,
which is not like climbing up the list
of,
of causes of death and tripling.
I'm glad you brought up alzheimer's
because I read something recently.
I didn't read the whole article.
I just read the title of it was
connecting alzheimer's to gut bacteria.
Yeah,
absolutely.
There's a strong that this,
this actually something referred to as
the gut brain access,
which is this very well known connection
between the gut and the brain and it
goes both ways.
So you know,
the gut can influence the brain strongly
and the brain can influence the gut
strongly.
So,
I mean,
my,
my point is just that what you said,
when are we going to realize that just
these changes,
you know,
making these changes is what we need to
do to prevent and reverse chronic
disease.
And,
uh,
we have these examples of people like
that that show us very clearly that it's
the way we're living,
not our genes that are causing this
chronic disease epidemic.
So the easy way would be to,
you know,
write books about it,
have shows like this,
keep educating people and doing that.
And that's what I'm hoping for and
that's why I wrote my book.
Um,
but the hard way is that our system
fails,
that it becomes so overburdened by the
rising rates of chronic disease and the
unsustainable expenses of that,
that it,
it basically falls apart and it becomes,
you know,
we respond in a kind of to it as the
crisis that it really is because it
becomes apparent at that point that
there are way that we've been doing it
has not been working and that we
desperately need to find a new way.
Um,
and that's another possibilitY.
And which one you think is gonna take
place,
kind of depends on whether you're a
glass is half empty or glass is half
full type of person.
Yeah.
Well,
from your own personal point of view,
if you're listening to this,
don't rely on all those things to
happen.
Just try to go out and do something
about this for yourself.
And I think that's how it's really gonna
you know my,
my personal view is it's going to be a
little of both actually.
So I think what's going to happen is
you're going to start seeing some big
changes on the more local grassroots
level.
So we've already seen stuff like this.
Examples of be a.
there's a group called iora health and
denver to primary care group and
they're,
they're reversing type two diabetes with
health coaches now.
They still see the doctor,
but they work primarily with a health
coach who does all those things that I
just said.
I wasn't making that up.
They actually go to their house.
They do pantry clean outs,
they go shopping with them.
They teach them how to eat well,
but more than that,
they just provide the,
the.
They're like the accountability buddy.
You know the person they call them every
week they,
they visit their house.
So how are you doing?
You know,
how can I help?
And,
and that person's totally empowered.
TheY make these changes and they're
reversing it without,
without drugs or with a minimum of
medication.
There's a mark hyman who's a doctor,
pioneer and functional medicine.
He recently,
um,
they tapped him to start the center for
functional medicine at the cleveland
clinic,
one of the most prestigious
international medical institutions
always on the forefront of the,
the,
the newest changes in medicine.
And when they first started,
they were in this tiny little space,
but within a few months they had like
3000 patients on their wait list and
they moved to a 17,000
square foot space and glickman tower,
which takes up the whole second floor of
this building and cleveland clinic.
And they've got patients from nine
countries on the waitlist coming from
all over the world to do the,
to do functional medicine because they,
you know,
people know that the system as it's set
up isn't really effective for chronic
disease.
It's fantastic.
I mean,
if I get hit by a bus,
I want to go to the hospital,
right?
I mean antibiotics revolutionize how we
treat infections.
You have anesthesia made surgery like,
you know,
imagine surgery without anesthesia.
It was like a bottle of booze.
I'm anti sepsis,
like cleaning the surgical theaters is
dramatically reduced infections.
You've got radiology,
radiologic images,
so that's improved diagnosis of disease.
So conventional medicine is amazing and
it's here to stay and we need it,
but it's just the wrong tool for the job
for long for chronic disease.
Nutrition,
for managing,
yeah,
using a hammer,
going around everywhere with a hammer,
you know,
expecting not to work.
Hammer works really well when you're
pounding a nail and it doesn't work as
well with a screw or you know,
with something else.
So I mean cleveland clinic,
it's just an amazing proof of concept
for functional medicine.
Then rob wolf,
who,
you know,
we both know,
he dId some incredible work with the
city of reno where,
and the first responders were,
they,
they projected that just by doing this
intervention.
So what happened was that the,
uh,
firefighters and police cops were,
were having heart attacks and strokes
and because of the way the pension
plans,
you know,
are set up if they have to,
if the city of reno has to medically
retire these,
these people,
they're gonna spend like millions of
dollars over the course of their
lifetime taking care of them.
so rob went in there with this other
group,
specialty health,
you got them on a good,
you know,
paleo type of diet,
lower carb diet,
got them doing some more physical
activity.
Well the estimate that they save the
city of reno,
something like 25 or $30 million dollars
just with this simple intervention.
We're doing a pilot now with the
berkeley fire department,
with our clinic with a similar kind of
goal.
So I think you're going to see all these
kind of examples of things happening on
local community level because you can
make changes more quickly that way.
And then over time some of those things
are going to scale up and you know,
we're going to start seeing them maybe
on the state level or the local
government level and then eventually at
some point that's going to get attention
of people on the federal level who are
looking around and going,
oh my god,
it's 20,
25 or 20,
30 healthcare expenditures are 35 or 40
percent of gdp.
This is completely unsustAinable.
Like we're,
we're not even going to exist as a
country in 25 years unless we do
something about this.
So I kinda think it's gonna gonna gonna
go like that.
Well,
I hope it goes towards the,
the,
the model of the cleveland clinic where
businesses sort of rise up and take
advantage of this opportunity to get
people healthy and to profit.
I mean,
it seems like that's the best way to
make things happen.
Make,
makes,
make it a business or someone can profit
off of it,
you know,
and as long as it's affordable for the
vast majority of people,
if it's not unreasonable.
Well that's the thing.
And,
you know,
rob has talked about this a lot for
years,
um,
if you look at economies of scale and
you looked at things like micro
microprocessors and dna testing,
you know,
the first human genome sequence was like
a bill costs like $500,000,000
right now you can just go out and pay
200 bucks to have the genome sequenced.
And you know,
microprocessors when they were first
introduced to computers were as big as
the room and um,
you know,
millions of dollars and now anyone can
go buy a computer for a few hundred
bucks while your phone is many times
stronger than is from nasa and the 1960
[inaudible].
But we don't see that kind of innovation
in healthcare.
Like we see expenses going up instead of
going down every year.
It gets more expensive.
I feel like there's a lot of hijacking
going on with big money and big money
in,
particularly in the pharmaceutical
industry.
They don't want anything.
They didn't do this,
this,
this gravy train of money going right
into their pockets when people have
disease.
And that's the key point.
I mean,
uh,
rob,
we did a,
what we call it,
a rally to end chronic disease the other
night,
and then rob came and spoke and so did
mark hyman from cleveland clinic and a
few others,
and in rob's talk he mentioned that
healthcare should essentially be free if
we used,
If,
if we allowed the same forces to that
microprocessor.
Microprocessors go from being extremely
expensive,
extremely cheap.
Dna testing go from being extremely
expensive to extremely cheap.
If we allowed those same forces to work
in on healthcare,
healthcare would be extremely
affordable.
The problem is,
as you pointed out,
we have a lot of misaligned incentives,
so insurance companies,
for example,
they only benefit when the overall
healthcare expenditures rise.
So the,
the more procedures are ordered,
tests are ordered,
you know,
treatments are prescribed.
The more they know the insurance company
benefit.
That seems counterintuitive to people
because you would think that
paying for insurance and the insurance
company is hoping that nothing goes
wrong because then they'll have to pay
out far more than that.
Paying.
Yeah.
There's a great book called catastrophic
care that I recommend for anyone by
david goldhill for anyone who is
interested in,
so it really pulls the curtain back on
the whole system and how it's set up.
Then you've got,
of course,
pharmaceutical companies.
How is it set of the why?
Why do insurance companies benefit from,
from things going wrong?
They,
as the,
as the whole edifice or the whole system
of healthcare grows,
they benefit because they're,
uh,
their recipient.
They're involved in all of those
transactions.
Oh,
okay.
And then you have big pharma that um,
is basically,
you know,
their incentive is to sell more drugs
and they're for profit corporations and
their duty is to make a profit for
shareholders and that's how they do it.
And so I'm selling more drugs is not
always in the same.
It aligned with the interest of patients
or even have doctors.
Well,
the real issue to me
that stands out as an example of that is
these stupid fucking commercials that
they have for pharmaceutical drugs where
people are having the best time ever
when you're looking at them and like,
how is this is so deceptive.
You're,
you're showing me like best case
scenario,
grandpa running,
pushing the bike and the little kids
laughing and everyone's having the time
of their life like,
oh,
I want the time of my life.
How do I get in on that?
Tell the last 15 or 30 seconds,
which is like
this drug may cause you know,
explosive diarrhea,
anal bleeding,
eyeballs fall out,
your feet don't work.
It's quite seriously.
Go on for like 15 seconds.
What was that one that we saw the other
day?
Jake humira.
Yeah.
What is that stuff?
It was for members.
She said it's like 120 grand for crap.
Crappy titus and death is a side effect
of that.
Drug death,
suicidal thoughts.
Contact your physician and he'll tell
you a fuck yourself.
Wake him up.
Wake him up in the middle of the night
here.
Give me some volume on this.
We could hear this when I was doing
okay.
I thought I was doing okay too,
but I'm not looking at was.
She's managing humira is for people to
still have symptoms of moderate to
severe crones disease.
Clinical studies,
the majority of people on humira saw
significant symptom
relief,
maybe achieved remission can tell you
what significant means.
Tuberculosis,
serious,
sometimes fatal infections and cancers
including lymphoma,
have happened,
have blood,
liver and nervous system problems,
serious allergic reactions and new or
worsening heart failure before
treatment.
Get tested for tb.
Tell your doctor if you've been to areas
where certain fungal infections are
common and if you've had tb.
Hepatitis b are prone to infections or
have flu like symptoms or sores.
Don't start humira.
If you have an infection,
just managing your symptoms.
Okay,
kill it right there.
Why is that lady so fucking sweet and
cheery?
What she's talking about?
Eminent death and the music just is not.
It is not fair and look,
the woman is on a tv set to like she's a
successful producer on a television set.
What a bizarre choice for what she does
for a living,
like watcher will kill the volume,
but watch her wander around the office.
They're like,
who the fuck works a tv show like this
is?
We're supposed to relate to this lady.
How manY people work on the set?
Look at her.
She's got a folder.
She goes,
she goes,
yeah,
because even though she has to do with
crohn's disease,
what you eat,
she's going to fucking die in an
explosive,
imploding,
rectal or disaster.
get an infection.
That would be totally,
you know,
not not a threat for you or anyone else,
but because they had taken a drug that
globally suppresses their immune system
can kill you.
Yeah.
That,
that whole thing,
like if you're,
you know,
if you have an infection,
don't take it.
Like,
what?
Wait a minute.
Aren't those pretty common,
the fuck are you saying like kind of try
not to get in fact don't get an
infection while you're taking humira.
It's like,
do you ever try to get an infection?
I mean,
how do you not try to get an infection?
Yeah,
this,
but this is what kills me is that
bizarre choice of her being some sort of
a director or producer of a television
show,
like they were supposed to relate.
Well,
she is so successful and maybe maybe if
you take humira,
you could also become a producer of a
television.
There was another one abilify that
killed and it was a antidepressant that
you give to people that are suicidal
while taking antidepressants.
Yeah,
like what?
Yeah.
Hey.
Yeah,
let's talk about abilify.
It's one of,
I think it's the sixth or seventh most
prescribed drug in the us.
It's an anti psychotic.
Okay.
So if those two things don't,
aren't,
are not resonating and there's a reason
for that.
We don't have that many psychotics in
this country where abilify could be,
you know,
only uses an anti psychotic.
Give me some volume.
Let's hear this carry on.
But other days I still struggled with my
depression.
I was handling it,
but sometimes it's just a cartoon.
I've been feeling stuck for a long time,
so I talked to my doctor and she added
abilify to my antidepressant.
She said it could help with my
depression and that some people had
symptom improvement as early as one to
two weeks.
I'm glad I talked to her.
I wiSh I'd done it sooner.
Now I feel more in control
of my new for everyone.
Doctor,
if your depression worsens or you have
unusual changes in behavior or thoughts
of suicide,
antidepressants can increase these in
children,
teens,
and young adults.
elderly dementia,
patients taking abilify have an
increased risk of death or stroke.
Call your doctor if you have high fever,
stiff muscles and confusion to address a
possible life threatening condition,
or if you have uncontrollable muscle
movements as these could become
permanent blood sugar has been reported
with abilify and medicines like it and
in extreme cases can lead to coma or
death.
Other risks include increased
cholesterol,
weight gain decreases in white blood
cells,
which can be serious,
dizziness on standing,
seizures,
trouble swallowing,
and impaired judgement or motor skills.
The person was always hanging over me.
That bitch,
a depressed depression is a concern.
If you take this shit.
Most of that commercial was telling
start where they're talking to,
you cut the segment of the commercial
where the lady comes out,
the doctor comes out,
show where the lady doctor is,
because that's like halfway in the lady
doctor comes out at third and two thirds
is the lady doctor say you're gonna
fucking die.
Wait
is break this down because this is a
drug that's added to a prescription of
someone who's already taking any
depressants to prevent suicidal thoughts
or.
But then one of the first side effects
they said to look out for it.
Suicidal thoughts?
Yeah.
What?
maybe there'll be a third drug that
people who are already on
antidepressants and abilify can take for
the suicidal thoughts that abilify
wasn't able to get rid of from the
original antidepressant.
Yeah.
Maybe we're just being cynical and
depressed.
We just need to trust in that cartoon
lady with a great voice.
Is amnesia.
So loss.
I mean this is a good example.
We've all heard this term evidence
based,
right?
yeah,
and the idea is that conventional
medicine is evidenced based and
everything else is not.
Well,
that's total bs because this an abilify
is a great example.
It's an anti psychotic,
that's what it was approved for,
for psychosis and yes,
we have a lot of,
I mean recent events indicate that we do
have quite a few psych psych,
psychotic people,
um,
mass shootings,
et cetera,
but not that many,
you know,
not enough to make abilify that the
seventh leading a drug on a sales basis.
That's insane.
That's an insane number.
So what abilify is prescribed off label,
so off label means a way of using the
drug that has never been a studier or
approved by the fda for that particular
purpose.
So it's using a drug in a way that was
not originally studied.
How is that legal?
It's legal.
Doctors have the authority to prescribe
medications off label as long as they're
fda approved,
fda approved for something that's so
vast.
Majority of abilify prescriptions
therefore are label,
which means they've never been studied
or shown to be safe or effective for the
conditions that it's being prescribed
for.
So your doctor could legally prescribe
you birth control pills?
Yeah,
I mean it would be frowned upon and
maybe if they did that enough and it was
causing problems,
they would,
they would have to justify why they were
doing it,
but it's the missing key to abilify
for men,
gay female birth control pills,
like,
oh wow,
look at this.
Well,
it also means they can use it in a
population that hasn't been studied for.
So for example,
a drug has been studied and approved for
adults.
Did you see that?
It said not safe,
you know,
it shouldn't be used for children and
the elderly because it's never been
studied,
but that doesn't mean it's not being
prescribed for children or the elderly.
It's still definitely is.
But you know,
antidepressants have been shown to cause
to suicidal ideation in adolescents and
teenagers in particular,
and yet they are still often used in
that,
in that group,
even though they were never studied or
approved for that
population.
What is this one,
jamie?
A bill,
a bill top selling year seven
below the top selling.
Sorry.
It's a toxin while you're driving.
It's not the number seven.
It's a silly me.
So the top selling drug is an anti
psychotic,
is that real?
Is real,
but is it still the top selling drug
will whatever,
let's not even look.
But in 2014 it was the top selling drug
that is crazy,
has become the best selling drug in the
United States.
The alarms about the dangerous and
sometimes deadly side effects of anti
psychotics affecting children and the
elderly among others have been mounting
for years.
Wow,
that's terrifying.
Yeah.
And many of these symptoms could be
directly related to gut biome gut
bacteria and you might be able to nip it
in the bud with a change in diet,
uh,
with addressing the sedentary lifestyle
rigorous exercise.
So let,
let me tell you asked all these things.
Meantime,
it seems like what you're prescribing
like,
oh,
come on.
It can't be that easy.
Let me tell you a story.
It's actually the first chapter in my
book.
It's about a kid named leo that I
treated my clinic furious back.
He's eight years old,
eight years old.
When he came to see me,
we're like a rack when they,
when they came to the office because
they,
you know,
he had,
they were just totally worn down.
He would throw these epic tantrums where
he'd be screaming and crying and riding
on the floor for just the most random
stuff,
like trying to get his shoes tied is
they were going out the door or you
know,
not cutting the crust off his bread
sandwich and just the right way or
getting a stay on his favorite tee
shirt.
He had a super limited diet.
He had only a handful of foods.
All of them processed and refined like
toaster waffles,
bread,
crackers,
cookies,
etc.
Um,
you know,
they were concerned about nutrient
deficiency,
but every time they tried to
reintroduce,
like to introduce a different food,
he would go ballistic and they didn't
have the energy to fight him at every
meal.
He was really rigid about his behavior
and environment.
So like everything had to be just right.
If the toys in his room or range in just
the right way,
he,
he'd fly off the handle desks in this
classroom.
You know,
just the right way.
He'd fly off the handle.
He was really anxious in unfamiliar
environments,
so it's hard for them to leave the house
for even a few hours,
much less travel or go on vacations.
I mean,
this seems extreme,
but there are a lot of kids with these
kinds of behavioral disorders now.
He was not,
you know,
he's not alone.
Um,
so they took him to see doctors locally
and they started with the primary care
doctor,
then went to psychiatrist and then
several behavioral disorder specialists
actually down here at usc or ucla and
uh,
you know,
first diagnosed on the autism spectrum
and then eventually ocd and something
called sensory processing disorder,
which is like on the autism spectrum
where they're really sensitive to scent
scent,
sense input,
touch,
you know,
sound cetera.
So,
um,
they,
the doctors,
uh,
you know,
they were relieved at first to have
these diagnoses,
but very quickly it became apparent that
they were just labeled sort of symptoms.
it wasn't anything that actually gave
them information about what to do.
And then the doc when asked the doctor
what the treatment was,
the answer was medication.
So they first started with adderall,
which you mentioned earlier,
then rhydlin both stimulants and then
eventually antidepressants,
which again have not really been
approved.
It's safe or effective in kids and they
did help at least a little bit with some
of the symptoms,
but then he got a lot of brutal side
effects,
got pain,
dry mouth,
irritability,
headaches,
and the worst thing was severe sleep
disruption.
And he had two younger brothers and
sisters.
So it was parents definitely didn't need
more of that.
And the crazy thing throughout this
entire period,
not one of his doctors even hinted at
the possibility that something in its
diet or like a disrupted gut microbiome
or nutrient deficiency could even be
contributing to his symptoms.
Nobody even brought that up.
And that's not the exception.
That's the rule.
Um,
so,
you know,
his parents weren't thrilled about,
uh,
I mean,
they weren't thrilled about medicating
him,
but they did it because they had no
other option.
And nobody suggested that it could be
anything other than just,
you know,
something wrong with their,
their son.
But uh,
fortunately one of his mom's friends had
sent a couple of articles from my blog.
One was on the gut brain axis,
which we've been talking about.
Another was on all of the underlying
causes of behavioral disorders in kids.
So they brought him to my clinic.
Um,
we did a whole bunch of testing as I do
with all my new patients.
And not surprisingly,
we found he had a disrupted gut
microbiome.
He had cbo,
bacterial overgrowth in the intestine.
He had a non celiac,
gluten sensitivity and gluten was in
almost every food he was eating.
But he also had an intolerance of some
other proteins like dairy and soy and
corn and buckwheat,
which were in the toaster waffles.
He was eating every night.
Yeah,
deficiencies of vitamin d,
b,
12 fully and iron because he was eating
just flower,
basically flour and sugar.
And he had high levels of arsenic,
which is a heavy metal because the only
other beverage he would drink aside from
water was rice,
milk and rice.
Milk has been shown to have higher
levels of arsenic,
so if a kid's just pounding rice milk,
they could actually start to develop
levels of arsenic.
that could be problematic because that's
crazy because a lot of people think of
rice milk as a healthy beverage.
Right.
But,
so we start,
you know,
we started treating him,
which wasn't easy because of his ocd,
like tendencies.
It was really hard to get him to change
his diet.
Um,
so we just started focusing just on
those mechanisms that I talked about,
getting him some more nutrients and
treating his god and,
and dealing,
You know,
trying to get some of those things out
of his food initially,
just switching those brands of toaster
waffles so that at least they were made
from stuff that he wasn't clearly
reacting to.
And then gradually over time shifting
within,
within several weeks,
he was having fewer tantrums.
He was less set off by the things that
would have done that before.
About four months into the treatment,
his teacher called home from school and
was like,
where's leo?
You know,
what have you done with leo?
And who's this guy?
Who was sending the school,
it has plates because it had been
horrific for her as as his teacher at
school and you know,
to the point where it's parents often
had to come pick him up and bring them
home from school because he was so
disruptive.
Then I talked to leo's mom maybe six,
seven months into the treatment.
By then we had to follow up,
test back.
A lot of the issues that we set out to
address had been resolved is dieted,
expanded significantly.
He was eating foods that he would have
thrown against the wall just a few
months before he was more tolerant,
more affectionate.
I'm less controlling and rigid and just
better adjusted kid overall and at the
end of that time his mom said something
that really struck me and it's really.
It's why I wrote the book.
She said,
why don't more doctors know about this?
There's so many kids out there like leo
who are suffering from these kinds of
behavioral disorders,
but neither their parents,
northern doctors or even looking at this
other stuff like the diet and the gut
and all these things so it's not even a
consideration and that's why I want to
get this book out there because it's
like we can't know and and,
and treat what we're not even looking
for.
What's crazY is what you're saying is
revolutionary,
but it's not.
Right.
It's common sense,
right?
I mean it's food,
but the,
you've,
you essentially restructured the
ecosystem of this child's body and,
and brought them back to homeostasis.
You brought them back to some sort of,
some normal functioning.
Some and this poor kid was living with a
diet that
a giant percentage of our country is,
Is consuming.
A lot of kids are eating sugar cereals
in the morning and peanut butter and
jelly sandwiches and just white bread
and sugar is lunch packs with the
lunchable.
Although,
yeah,
it's even worse in kids because there's
this idea that big food has been very
successful.
It perpetuating that.
Kids need special kids foods.
You know,
they can't just eat what we're eating as
adults.
We have to prepare kids meals.
You go to a restaurant and there's the
kid's menu,
go to a great restaurant that has meat
and vegetables and all this stuff on
what is the kid's menu have on it?
Chicken fingers,
cheese,
pasta with nothing on it.
Just total crap bullshit.
And the idea,
you know,
when we go out with my daughter,
they always bring us the kid's menu and
my daughter's like,
no,
I don't need to see that.
I'm ordering off this menu.
And it's like,
yeah,
we don't need breakfast cereal or pop
tarts who need this craft kits just need
to eat.
It's even more important for kids to eat
well than it is for us because their
brain is still developing.
Their body's still developing.
So yeah,
I mean someday we'll go to the doctor
and you have a chronic,
you know,
something like this.
The first questions are going to be
around,
what are you eating?
How are you living?
Oh wait,
let's do some tests to find out how your
gut is.
Let's do some tests to see if you're
nutrient deficient.
Let's.
Let's actually look at the causes
instead of just assuming that every
chronic disease is a deficiency of a
medication.
Yeah.
That's basically how it's a problem.
You have high cholesterol,
you have a stat and deficiency,
so we better correct that by giving you
this.
You have high blood pressure,
you have a diarrhetic deficiency.
We're going to give you that.
You have depression,
you have an antidepressant deficiency,
so we're going to give you that drug.
Basically how it's looked at,
that is how it's looked at.
It's crazy that what you're saying is
eat food,
eat real food,
eat food.
I mean,
I think if people,
if we ate real food,
like probably that could shave off like
a couple trillion dollars from the
health care and how much more effective
would we be at whatever we're doing?
How much healthier would people be?
How much happier would people be?
yeah.
It's not just about health in that
narrow sense of the lIke the absence of
symptoms or the body.
we're talking about your ability to
perform at work,
your ability to relate to your kids,
to your partner,
you know,
wonder how much of the antidepressant,
like the people that are prescribed are
people that are experiencing depression,
has to do with their diet.
I would say quite a high percentage.
Again,
I don't want to be.
I think there are situational factors
that cause depression.
I mean,
you know,
for someone who is poor and lives in an
economically and socially depressed area
and is fighting,
you know,
systemic oppression,
there's good reason to be depressed
situation.
So nevertheless a,
given what we understand now about this
inflammatory model of depression,
it's also true that that is the very
least going to exacerbate it and make
it,
but in some cases may be the primary
driver of depression and I can't tell
you how many patients I've had who've
had depression that they thought was.
IT was something wrong with them.
There's something broken about them.
you know,
they just,
they're not cut out for this world.
They don't fit in here.
That sort of thing.
And then we go in,
we see,
oh,
you've got a severe,
be 12 or fully deficiency that affects
your neurotransmitter levels.
Oh,
you've got a disrupted gut microbiome.
Oh you're,
you've got,
you know,
a blood sugar abnormalities.
Oh,
you're hypo thyroid.
We know 20 or 30 percent of patients
with depression have hypo thyroid.
So just correcting that could,
could correct it.
Can we address all Those things?
All of a sudden that person's no longer
depressed.
And I've had people say things like,
oh my god,
for the last 20 years I thought
something was wrong with me.
I thought I was broken.
I thought like I really.
It was me and something was really
wrong.
It's a crazy word too.
The problem with depression is that it's
a diagnosis and that if you just said
feel bad,
would not be like,
oh,
he's been diagnosed with feel bad,
you know.
But that's essential with depression is
it's so blanket.
It can cover a host of different
neurological issues,
physiological issues or behavioral
issues that are there because of your
environment and your life experiences.
Absolutely.
And that was not an unintentional thing,
joe,
that was a drug companies creating it as
a disease to that because diseases
require medications to be fixed in our
culture and this happens across the
board and it's not,
you know,
the story of viagara and how that was
developed.
It was some sort of a blood pressure
medication.
Correct.
Right.
And uh,
hey,
jack,
jackpot.
Yeah.
So they found like,
okay,
this isn't working very well for what we
designed it for,
but,
but it's got some pretty interesting
effects and so,
but they knew it wasn't enough to just
then go out there and start selling it
for two.
Got to say,
hey,
here's a drug that will help you know,
make you perform better,
right.
Bedroom.
That wasn't enough.
What they had to do is create a disease
that it could be prescribed for because
that's.
And then,
and,
and you know how they did that,
they hired a,
an advertising agency and the ad agency
came up with the term erectile
dysfunction.
No way.
And created this.
Absolutely.
It's publicly available information
agency named a disease.
this is not the only case where this has
happened,
so they create this disease category and
then they get it out into the world and
they advertise it to people and to
doctors and so all of a sudden people
are going in with a magazine or like,
this is me,
I have erectile dysfunction,
and I know now there's a drug called
viagara that I need because I have
erectile dysfunction and the doctor has
seen the.
They have their own brochure.
They pull out their brochure and it says
erectile dysfunction.
Here are the signs and symptoms.
Okay,
check,
check.
Yes.
This patient's got erectile ed.
So here's a drug.
Is it legal for an advertising
agency to name a disorder?
well,
I'll tell you that it's illegal in every
single country in the world except for
New Zealand and the United States to
advertise drugs to to consumers.
Please New Zealand.
Be the first change.
Please turn around,
make us look terrible at first because
this is the result.
Conscious is the result of allowing
drugs to be advertised is that you get
advertising agencies creating conditions
that then require drugs to be treated.
That is fucking amazing.
What else has been named by advertising
agencies?
Off the top of my head,
I don't know,
but I will.
Next time I'm on this show,
I'll definitely have a list for you.
God damn.
I can't believe that that's legal.
it's legal.
And you know,
I,
there's a,
another book I read a while back,
um,
and the quote in the book was really
revealing.
It was by the ceo of merck,
which is one of the biggest
pharmaceutical companies in the world.
And again,
I'm going To paraphrase,
I don't remember the exact words,
but the gist of it was the real money in
drugs is in selling them to healthy
people.
So he hit,
he had realized that,
you know,
we basically saturated the market of
medications that can be used to treat
sick people.
So the only way we can continue to grow
and expand is to come up with ways to
sell drugs to healthy people.
When did they first started prescribing
ended up presence?
Uh,
well the,
the ssri is I think go back to the
eighties,
late eighties,
early nineties,
but they had other kinds of
antidepressants before that called try
cyclic antidepressants and other types
of medications.
So they've been around for awhile,
but I mean,
my point is like this creation of ed,
erectile dysfunction as a disease was a
way of kind of selling drugs to healthy
people because they,
they,
they basically shifted them from being
healthy people that otherwise wouldn't
see themselves as someone who needed a
drug to people who are not who,
who now have a condition.
Yeah.
From what I understand,
pro vigil,
that was the initial creation of
provigil.
They were trying to come up with a
performance enhancing drug for,
for um,
cognitive function and they couldn't
just sell it as such,
so they had to come up with some sort of
a reason why people need it.
So they went with narcolepsy.
Right.
And then you,
I mean,
you have people who have been arguing
that stat and should be put in the water
supply.
Why?
Yeah.
There literally blew the fuck.
Says that as a doctor in the uk,
that guy's a monster who lit not cause
eating a salad right now.
Fucking monster put it in the water
supply.
Qmap is up.
That's poison.
He's seriously.
I advocated for that and it wasn't a
joke.
It wasn't an exaggeration.
This is a few years back.
I can't.
I have a blog article about it because
his argument was these,
you know,
these drugs are so effective for
reducing the risk of heart disease that
we should just be giving them to
everybody despite whether they
want to take them or not because it
doesn't that don't they seriously
disrupt performance.
Physical performance.
The bigger question is whether statens
actually extend lifespan in people
without preexisting heart disease and a
lot of the research suggests that not
that the answer to that question is no
or very in a,
in an almost non insignificant way and
then you have to balance that with the
potential side effects.
Like the increased risk of diabetes,
particularly in women with and now we
have 100 million people with diabetes
and then the muscle fatigue and myopathy
and that,
that sort of thing.
But uh,
yeah,
I mean I think this is,
I mean we go off on this when we are
talking about misaligned incentives and
all of these things we've been talking
about are just examples of how what's in
the best interests of a drug company de
is not necessarily in the best interest
of us as patients or as for dr.
When he goes back to what you were
saying about teeth,
tooth decay and fluoride in the water,
right?
Like how much tooth decay is really
because of our diet.
And it's not because of fluoride is not
because Florida is not good for you.
Well you look especially in large
quantities and you can get away with it
in some of the quantities.
It's in our water supply.
But from what I understand,
it's not really.
We don't need it.
So,
I know this might sound controversial,
but do we think that our 100 gatherer
ancestors were brushing their teeth
twice a day and flossing twice a day
now?
They probably had horrible breath.
Well,
here'S the thing,
um,
there is an oral microbiome just like
there is a microbiome in the gut and
it's what's likely and,
and they've archeologists have know that
when they,
you know,
when they uncover remains from the
traditional,
you know,
our ancestors,
our paleolithic ancestors,
they have great healthy jaws and teeth
and not egyptians.
You know,
about that.
Well,
that was civilization already.
Yeah.
Grinding food,
talking about further back,
further back in our history prior to
agriculture right now,
none of that.
And so what that suggests is that,
you know,
look,
I brushed my teeth and floss and not
suggesting that people shouldn't now and
that there hasn't been some improvement,
but that,
you know,
the fact that weston price went around
to all these traditional cultures and
found that they had beautiful healthy
teeth and wide dental arches.
They weren't brushing their teeth twice
a day and flossing twice a day,
but they had root underlying foundation
of health and a healthy microbiome,
not only in their gut but in oral
microbiome that lead to healthy teeth.
Even without that kind of dental hygiene
and dental care.
And uh,
you know,
there are now oral probiotics,
dental probiotics,
which are chewable tablets that you can
just,
you know,
you pop one in your mouth after you
brush your teeth,
you chew.
And I've had patients who had been
having recurring cavities,
dental issues,
period per
periodontal periodontal issues that just
by chewing one of these dental
probiotics twice a day,
I've had like a complete reversal on
their dental health where,
you know,
they go from having like a cavity every
time they go to the dentist to having no
cavities at all
because that was,
that's one of those woo subjects where
people go,
oh,
you fucking crystal hippie.
You know,
when you start talking about fluoride in
the water.
But do we really.
I mean,
we definitely need to somehow or another
clean the water of bacteria and treat
the water so that it doesn't have
pollutants in it,
but that can be done with filtration
systems.
You know,
people in the wild,
not in the wild,
meAning like the toumani,
but people that live in camps for months
at a time,
like friends of mine,
they go on these back country trips.
They use water filters to use.
They'll take a walk,
they'll take like a wallow that like an
elk have been stomping around and muddy
water and they'll put this water through
this filtration system and make it so
you can drink it and there's stary pens.
They have these pens that you could spin
the pan around the water for a
predetermined period of time and it
kills everything.
That's bacteria.
All the bacteria in the water.
There's a bunch of different filtration
systems,
pumps that they use on creeks to keep
beaver fever.
What's that stuff called?
Giardia.
Giardia from beaver.
Shit in the water.
So this all can be done without
chemicals.
that was my point.
Yeah,
so the chemicals that we have in the
water there,
they might be terrible for you.
They're not necessary and especially in
terms of flUoride,
it might be completely misguided.
Have you read,
I forget the book on this big thick book
on fluoride.
Bryson,
I think this is the last name of the
author.
It's a yellow cover.
no,
I haven't read it.
I think he mentioned something about how
in this this comes up in other contexts
too,
um,
where,
uh,
companies that have something that's
toxic that they would otherwise have to
pay for to dispose of.
I have figured out ways to actually sell
that stuff to the food industry or to
another industry that,
that then puts it in some products.
So industrial seed oils like soybean
oil,
cottonseed oil,
those kinds of things.
Originally were,
were not considered foods.
They were waste products from ag
agriculture from text growing those
crops.
And then the,
the brilliance of those that have those
companies at that time was figuring out
a way to turn those things that would
have otherwise been seen as waste into
like a food product that they could then
sell.
And make money off of really those,
those,
those are amongst the worst because you
know,
those are ubiquitous in the american
diet,
like if you pick up any package food,
you're going to see,
you know,
soybean oil,
corn oil,
cottonseed oil,
et cetera.
There's all these highly processed and
refined omega six vegetable oils.
And those vegetable oils are very
difficult for your body to process well
there.
First of all,
they're almost completely devoid of
nutrients.
They have,
you know,
some of them have vitamin e,
but they have almost no other nutrients
at all.
Um,
and historically humans had consumed a
balance of omega six and omega three
oils that was somewhere between,
you know,
one to one ratio or maybe a four to one
in favor of omega six.
But,
uh,
the amount of omega six oils that we
consume today is much higher,
you know,
sometimes like a 20 to one ratio of
omega six to omega three.
And this is a controversial topic.
There was just a research study
published that was a,
seemed to suggest that these oils
actually may not be as harmful as as we
thought they were,
but I haven't had a chance to read the
full text of the study yet.
And you have to look at the overall
weight of the evidence,
you know,
if you've got 40 studies showing that
there are harmful and then one that
shows that they're not well.
Okay,
but you got to consider that in the
whole context.
Yeah.
And you got to find out who funded that
study and there are a lot of questions
to ask and whether even the studies said
what,
what people say it said,
which is often not the case when you
look into it.
That fluoride one's really freaking me
out now that we're talking about it
because I wonder like,
how do you,
how would you ever stop that?
What's the.
Hasn't there been connections or
correlations between fluoride and low
iq?
That sounds familiar,
but again,
it's not topic I've looked into in
detail.
So I don't want to say something that's
not correct,
but um,
that's the difference in you and me.
I think I heard fluoride exposure in
utero linked to your iq in bed study
says,
can you go scroll up a little bit there,
jamie?
Let me.
They'll.
Yeah.
Increased levels of prenatal fluoride
exposure may be associated with lower
cognitive function in children.
New study says published tuesday and the
journal of environmental health
perspectives evaluated nearly 300 sets
of mothers and children in Mexico and
tested children twice for cognitive
development over the course of 12 years.
Florida is not added to public water
supplies in Mexico,
but people are exposed to it through
naturally occurring fluoride in water
and fluoridated salt and supplements.
Wow.
yeah.
And the,
I mean this highlight something else
that we haven't talked about much at all
in terms of aspect of the modern
environment.
It's problematic,
which is toxins being one of them,
but also things like mercury,
bisphenol a,
bpa which is in the plastic water
bottles,
seats,
and what's this?
Thousands of us locales.
We're lit.
We're lead poisoning is worse than.
yeah.
Yeah.
Did you see that new study on India?
I think it was new delhi,
I forget what,
but air pollution in India
at an all time high and they show these
photographs of this city and
it is insane.
You just can't see anything.
I can't see anything.
You can't see a building 100 yards ahead
of you.
Yeah.
So I mean air pollution has been linked
to obesity and cardiovascular disease
and stuff.
You wouldn't even think,
not just respiratory,
you know,
things like systemic inflammatory
conditions.
And the problem with toxins is our
initial understanding of toxic toxicity
was only like acute toxicity.
Like what happens if you get so much
mercury in your body so quickly that it
causes like an acute problem and we
assume that um,
you know,
if,
if you don't see acute toxicity then
there's no problem.
Like There's nothing in between acute
toxicity and just normal that we know
now that like there was a really
interesting study a couple years back.
I wrote about this on my blog.
I think the title was something like
mercury,
a fish consumption and kids.
Look at this video.
The video came out today,
this is a really bad,
uh,
air pollution caused car accident pile
up in new delhi that these people are
trying to get people out of the car and
just a couple of seconds it's just like
a snow storm here in America and other
cars and it comes slamming into them.
Oh,
they're going to tell them to hurry up
and get the fuck out of there before
another one comes in.
It happens like three or four times in a
row right here.
Oh my god.
So these.
So these people are standing there and
see,
oh my god,
mrs.
On a freeway.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Now they gotta get the fuck out because
another one's coming.
It's insane.
Oh my god.
This is all just air pollution there.
This is incredible.
This is like,
they're in a fog on a mountain road and
were on the highway.
this is what is the name of this video?
So you can watch on twitter.
I define on twitter litter going around
the dassault right before the show
starts.
That's why I was like,
oh my god.
New delhi car accident,
uh,
air pollution.
Oh my god,
this is insane.
And they're telling these people get out
of the car.
what do you do?
Because if you go up to try to warn
people it's they can't see you there
either.
Yeah.
And then what if someone takes a turn
and it hits those people to the side?
Oh god,
this is horrific.
That's about where it ends right here.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
So I mean,
these are like the mercury thing,
you know,
the idea for a long time was,
oh,
if your blood levels below 10 parts per
million,
you're fine.
There's no evidence,
you know,
there's no,
there's no issue.
So this new study came out and they
looked at kids and they looked at
cortisol levels,
which and in and inflammatory
inflammatory markers and they found that
kids that,
that had mercury levels that were even
as,
as low as a one,
so you know,
almost 10 times lower than the level of
concern had higher levels of cortisol
and higher levels of inflammatory
markers and they and they.
So that totally turned things on the,
on,
on their head.
It was like all of a sudden,
you know,
lower levels of the talks of these
toxins than we thought were problematic
are actually problematic and they,
when they dove in and look deeper,
they found a,
you know,
some of the kids who were affected had
certain genetic polymorphisms,
like there was something that made them
more susceptible or maybe they had
nutrient deficiencies that made them
less able to detoxify the mercury as
they normally should be able to.
And you know,
what further complicates it is that,
uh,
the symptoms that you see with high
levels of toxin can actually be
different at low levels.
So let's say researchers design a study
to see the toxic effects of mercury
when,
when the exposure is severe and they're
looking for certain studies and then
they start lowering the dose of mercury
to see when those effects go away,
they will completely miss the effects
that are caused by the low doses of
mercury because they're are different
than the effects that they were studying
at the higher doses.
So this caused a problem for years where
it was assumed that the low doses were
harmless because they weren't observing
the same effects they saw at the high
doses and now they know this and so
they've redesigned studies to look,
just cast a wider net and see what's
happening.
And sure enough at those lower levels of
toxins they're seeing all kinds of
effects that are actually in some cases,
opposite of the effect that you see with
the high dose of the toxin.
Have you adjusted like where you live or
anything because of all this?
Uh,
well I,
you know,
when we're,
we just bought a house a couple of years
ago and we just um,
you know,
we had a choice of where to live.
We wanted to live in berkeley.
That's where my offices.
And so we ended up living up on,
on top of the hill and that was somewhat
intentional for me.
It's right near tilden park,
which is a outdoor regional park space
with a lot of green area and stuff.
And,
and there are parts of berkeley that,
you know,
where the air quality is really,
really bad.
Like surprising if you don't,
if you don't know that area,
if you go online to some of these air
quality ratings sites,
you can see that parts of berkeley or
like c minus or d,
um,
because there's so much industry there
and the chevron plan and stuff,
but this is where it gets really,
you know,
the inequalities is brutal because guess
who ends up often living in the areas
that are most toxic are the people who
are economically disadvantaged and
they're the least influential when it
comes to any kind of political power to,
to change,
make changes in those areas.
So it's unfair.
It's,
it's,
and they're disproportionately affected
by that because they,
nobody's watching out for them.
Yeah.
Well there's,
there's a lot of it,
a lot of
factors we could talk about,
but I think,
uh,
it's just,
it's so important that there's people
like you out there that are highlighting
these things,
are writing books about these things and
talking about these things on podcast.
So thank you so much,
man.
Thank you for your book and thank you
for that.
Pleasure.
Last time you were here,
we learned so much too,
so tell people one more time the name of
the book where to get it.
Yeah,
it's unconventional medicine.
You can get it on amazon and also a
unconventional medicine book.com.
You can actually download the first
three chapters for free.
Do it.
Get on it,
change your health folks.
Get your shit together.
Thank you chris.
Really appreciate it.
Always.
Great to see you too,
man.
Thank you.